foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Norway Lander fjords Majestic mountains
Cliffs and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdu
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakriya
mamagyarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field
who will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
hello and welcome to the 11th edition of
noise
and it is here in Stavanger where some
of the world's biggest and brightest
players including Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura and Fabiano Carona just to name
a few are getting ready to play some
Lightning Fast chess hold on to your
seats it's gonna be an adrenaline packed
show I'm International Marcy Ivanka
houska and it is a great pleasure to be
here calling all the action alongside
the one and only Grand Master Judith
poga and of course commentator and
Grandmaster extraordinaire David Howell
so Judith how excited are you to be here
oh I'm very excited I'm so happy to be
back here we are next door to the
playing Hall and I think the players are
also so happy I I just want to see fire
today fire on the board and David you've
actually recently been commentating on
the
and now you're in Norway chess
commenting here what's it like well it's
been a busy week Ivanka it's a lot of
Chess but I'm impressed by the player's
stamina some players like chess kid Cup
winner Abdul satorov are here now ready
to get going and like you Judith I'm
excited about the blitz we're about to
see yeah
because when wait till you look at this
because when we're talking about Norway
chess we're talking about an impressive
field we have some of the world's best
and brightest players and just take a
look at some of those names former world
champion Magnus Carlson Wesley so
farouza Hikaru Nakamura anishikiri
Fabiana caruana Shakira mamajarov
nordebec abdusator of just 18 years old
Ari antari and a man who celebrated his
birthday 17 year old gukash and David I
have to ask you who are your favorites
here well I'm excited to see all of
these players what a stacked field but
uh Magnus Carlsen he's got to start as
the guy to beat he has made this his
home territory we're here in Norway he's
won the event so many times uh other
than him I'm going to single out of this
tour of winner of the chess kid cup and
a man on form well I'm I'm really
excited to see these youngsters how they
are going to be playing and the gokash
who is this so young at the sator of but
of course the old timers some of them
you can call like that right it's it's
really exciting it's gonna be exciting
because we have some of the world's most
dynamic players versus butting heads
against the world's best teenagers and
uh well today it is the blitz event and
it is a precursor to the classical event
and it's there to determine the
classical event seating which means that
the person who finishes first will
actually get the first pickings and it
continues so on it's a 10 player single
round robin and is paid at a very fast
three minutes plus two seconds per move
one point per win and half a point for a
draw and now the first five seedings
will get that extra white dude how
important is it to get that extra white
when I was still in competitive chess I
have to say that I was very much looking
forward to have extra weight especially
for players who are very active and
taking initiative so extra wide is
really something that you're looking
forward as a player and what do you
think David yeah it's uh the extra white
of course is a bonus but for me it's
about showing their form showing their
confidence and these players they will
be wanting to win they will be wanting
to stamp their mark on the tournament
and that starts with the blitz of course
and uh do you think it's an indicator
you know if you do a good performance
here will it be a good sign for the
classical event yeah the players who
play well in the blitz their future
opponents are going to fear them when
the classical chess starts and uh with
this unique format in norwichs games
drawn games in the classical decided by
Armageddon I think this is a great way
for the players to get in the right Zone
and talking about a great way well we
have something very special installed
because take a look at these first round
matchups I mean we could not ask for a
better start than this and the
headlining is uh Anish giri against
Magnus Carlson Magnus Carlson is such a
blitz specialist then we have Wesley so
Hikaru Nakamura alireza farouza the
world's strongest teenager against
orientare gukash celebrating his
birthday today for against Fabiana
caruana Shakira mamajarov against Nordic
abdusotoff and Judith which match do you
have your eye on well I'm consistent so
I want to see gokesh against Furby and
I'm the Sutter of game with mamajaro
because I think there are a lot of
excitement going on later and you David
yeah the All-American matchup between
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so it's going
to be fascinating two speed Specialists
facing each other of course but for me
the headline of this round anishikiri
against Magnus Carlson a friendly
rivalry but a rivalry nonetheless
certainly I mean we do see that Magnus
has been in great shape especially when
it comes to Blitz and Tick Tock that
talk that clock is ticking down and
there we see the players all lined up
they are getting ready we see a niche
with the white pieces his jackets off
absolutely let's move number one
and then he does the typical chess
player thing of adjusting the pieces
getting ready to face Magnus Carlson and
of course the two did play each other in
the recent superbet tournament yeah just
in Romania last week anishagiri faced
off against Magnus Carlson actually
Magnus Carlson was dominant in that
field winning the blitz portion winning
the whole event uh so it's no surprise
to see Magnus turning up late that's
customary for him by now and we do see
also see farrugia against Harry on Oscar
in a big clash between uh two good
friends yeah everywhere you look in this
round there's going to be action fire on
the board it's very difficult to
determine we know which game is going to
be more exciting because these guys are
just simply incredible and we see Ariane
there with the black pieces getting in
the zone and Fabiano as well facing off
against 17 year old gukash incidentally
it's his birthday I've said it twice I
mean how difficult is it to play on your
birthday well to be honest I was not
very successful on my birthdays but I
think he's quite focused as we can and
see right now so he did not celebrate
much his birthday but he might be
interested to celebrate with the victory
today not only in this game but maybe
the tournament itself
yeah good cash uh I actually just saw a
graphic recently he's the second highest
rated 16 year old of all time but now
he's 17 can he go even further I think
that's the big question uh Fabi of
course in great form recently in the
chess kid cup just last week he got to
the final uh where he fell to Abdul
satoroff but either way his Blitz and
Rapid skills have improved enormously
Fabiano yeah absolutely and I also saw
some stats on the younger cashino's
first player to cross 2700 first the
youngest player so not the first player
to cross 2700 the youngest player to
cross 2700 the youngest player to beat
Magnus Carlson and uh well he has the
white pieces against Fabiano and kakash
incidentally has been playing a lot of
tournaments so far and someone else
who's playing a lot of tournaments
um there we see Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura now these guys have played each
other countless times
and very recently in the American Cup it
was Hikaru who was the Victor when it
came to their encounters yeah Hikaru
tends to be dominant in this matchup
just in recent times he's also been uh
taking down Wesley in Armageddon usually
over the Champions chess tour so this
one is going to be a decisive Clash I
think for the tournament standings later
on they'll both be up there for sure and
they'll will want to start on a high
Wesley meanwhile looking off into this
distance I like the two kind of
different postures they have here Hikaru
didn't have a great event last week on
the Champions chess tour where he was
actually playing from Stavanger so he
will be hoping that he can right those
wrongs and play a bit better this week
yeah and incidentally Wesley so has been
a previous Blitz event a winner he's won
it twice including last year
well we see
animation is kind of
focused waiting the opponent who is not
other than world number one
is he still preparing or what is he
doing Gary was like that that he was
always coming in the last very last
second
is that a psychological Ploy do you
think Judith just arriving late to
assert your dominance over the opponent
well I think Gary was absolutely doing
it for psychological reasons but it also
had to do the fact that there were a lot
of photographers and there was no Zero
Tolerance at the time so there was five
minutes when people could make pictures
he showed up like 50 seconds before and
then all the flashes went into his eyes
but we see the game starts yeah and
we're off Magnus sits down takes his
jacket off but Anish has been the first
to move no repeat this time of Magnus
arriving two and a half minutes late
like we saw during the World
Championship the Blitz World
Championship and uh okay one E4 Anish
gets away from the board this time wow
some mind games at this early stage
Junior well with three minutes on your
clock with two extra seconds it seems
like they have their ideas how to spend
those extra seconds just looking around
wow but now it will speed up for sure
and Fast and Furious but furiously away
from the board and it's the Sicilian
Defense it's one of my favorite favorite
variations is the alapin the C3 Sicilian
and uh I've not actually seen any employ
this one too much but Magnus has a lot
of experience on the black side so it
feels like deep preparation well it's
interesting that nowadays of course
players have different uh preparations
for Blitz Games for Rapid for classical
right they have completely different
ideas to try out
and now Bishop D3 went back yeah and how
important is it to get that surprise
value so that we see a pawn trade in the
center
yeah I think for Magnus he prizes
surprise value just uh as maybe the
number one priority especially in Blitz
chess he'll play all sorts of openings
just to confuse the opponent just to
gain a few extra seconds on the clock as
they recover from a surprise but I think
these two players at the moment they
just have so much respect for each other
that they're just playing their main
repertoires and uh okay white has more
space in this position but black looks
super solitude but I think it's also
important for them to entertain them
entertain themselves and that's why also
they like to play out some completely
random things or ideas which they would
practically would not go in a classical
game or not even in Rapid games but of
course Blitz is completely different
because if they get an ID and they make
the other one think for a minute let's
say that's a huge Advantage so it's a
huge psychological battle I think
especially in these Blitz Games but it
seems like black wants to simplify the
position exchange the bishop now the
Knight and the queen is trying to be
exchanged of course if once the black
knight from B6 goes to D5 after
exchanges black can have a beautiful
position
but Anish is not going to exchange
Queens here of course he wants to go out
to B5 I think
yeah some threats on the board already
and wow insisting on the exchange of
Queens so black has a great position I
believe
yeah and it's right up Magnus Carlson's
alley it's right up his style to just
trade pieces and in this end game
there's enough imbalance with black uh
with White's far Advanced e-pawn but uh
there's something to chew on if all the
pieces come off I think black will have
an advantage actually uh just because
white has a bit more space and uh maybe
not the pieces to control those squares
well I think it will depend very much
who is going to be coming first with
both of the Rooks to the open file
whether the Rook to C8 and the other one
from the corner to a from h a to d8 of
course we can see that now the bishop
developed to E7 so Black's only problem
could be how to get out the Rook from h8
because if black has to Castle it's
maybe not something that the Magnus
would be happy with because then the
king is very far away in the end game
but still somehow the HH Rook has to
come to d8 then black would be better
because black would have a great
advantage in development but King F1
very logical right coming to the center
to E2
to defend that weak d square
and only later Anish wants to develop
with his Bishop from C1 maybe he's still
hesitating to E3 to G5 possibly to
exchange or to F4 depending how black is
going to be continuing the game
yeah Moment of Truth will be about to be
seen do you think Magnus is going to
Castle Ivanka again it's against his
religion really to move the king away
from the center in an endgame absolutely
not I I think he'll keep his King in the
middle and try to initiate some trades
and uh well there's consequences of
White's last move and the Knight does
spring forward
and now we see a trade Bishop four
Knight and Anish I have to say is
playing very quickly and to my eyes it
feels like Anish knows what he's doing
he's could he be in prep
I'm not so sure he's down he's only got
about one minute and 10 seconds one
minute and 12 there Anish giri and again
now there's another imbalance in the
position it's not just in terms of Pawn
structure it's in terms of pieces Bishop
for Knight exchange well and now both
bones are hanging E5 and B2 at the same
time so white has to be somehow very
fast on this so Knight E4 is kind of
logical now black Rook should he go to
B5 go back to C8 then Rook C1 is
possible so pinning the Knight on C4
that's what I would like to play with
white because suddenly you see that
white species are very active both Rooks
could not place anywhere better than
that and still black king is on the
eighth and finally Castle came
yeah but now Rook D7 just cannot be
played because of Knight E3 so that
would be a blunder yeah you want to
bring the Rook up of course but then
this Rook would be undefended so the
Black Knight would jump out the way and
discovered attack against this Rook
tactic student it certainly is tactics
but uh it's still very much in the air
I I yeah you know you can't play it now
but uh it's not easy for the the black
Rook on f8 to actually Challenge on d8
well probably now it becomes tactical or
possibly B3 could be the move and then
Black Knight will be pushed back to B6
which is not a very good placement for
the Knight but if it ends up on the E5
as we discussed it before then it can be
interesting for black king E2 giving up
the B2 Pawn for the moment
wow this has to be accurately calculated
by a niche do you think Magnus is going
to take the B2 Pawn
feels like at some point maybe after a
rook trade the white Rook could uh come
up to D7
suddenly everything getting traded off
does Magnus want to keep control he's
calculating right now well I think it's
a momentum in this game also I would
consider to play sometimes F5 trying to
force white to decide where you want to
go with the knight from E4 or you want
to take them pass on F6 and then also
there is an open way for the black king
to F7 and then to come to E6 later on
so there it's an important moment I
think at this point and only 17 seconds
for Anish and Magnus still has 40. so I
think it's important moment to decide
right now because after Knight takes on
B2 white is going to be exchanging the
Rooks and then puts the Rook on the
seventh rank attacking the B7 pawn and
the bishop on E7 so Knight B6 I'm not
surprised at all that he went back to
cover that important Square yeah
covering D7 and uh Anish now maneuvering
than white Knights just H5 do you see
that move
that surprised me and I know Magnus
loves to push his Rook spawns his
h-pawns but finally the king is out and
we're playing G6 and F5 what do you
think about that I love it activate the
king at any cost yeah
deep stuff I have to say I was impressed
by it anisha's uh maneuvers you know
putting the Knight back to the edge of
the board and okay well we have a trade
of Rooks and what about this ending I
mean I was always taught that Two of a
Kind better than one one of a kind so
what do you think two nights well now
the big question is can black go King F5
but probably Knight D6 seems to be very
strong after that black is in trouble so
he played B6 F4 now black once white
wants to go G4 in the next move F5
finally look at that
you predicted it Judith about 10 15
moves ago F5 is calm and okay
everything's getting hoovered off the
board Bishops normally tend to be better
than Knights when they're spawns on both
sides of the board but here it's just
not enough simplification goes towards
being a draw but of course time is going
down and suddenly Magnus has uh less
time for the first time in this game
yep the White Knight will sit on a
square that it can Target Black's F5
Pawn there we go and it ties down the
black king I think this might be the
problem you just cannot break the uh
status quo right now but Magnus he's
hinting that he wants to go and capture
the Knight King and porn end games if
the minor pieces disappear will be
treacherous for both sides what do we
think are we about to see a draw we just
second time we've seen this position but
uh Magnus actually said no you know he
was given the opportunity to repeat the
bishop maneuver but instead that hasn't
happened and but he has like five
seconds left are you sure that he want
to play for a win with black
maybe you've got to set the tone for the
game and uh well what do we think about
this uh Pawn advancing on the queen side
because it does give some squares for
the white king
to jump to well we see that Magnus is in
the real fighting Spirit today
he does not want to agree to draw here
he can get in trouble Knight C4
blundering the pawn on A5 look at that
wow just no time of the clock for Magnus
under five seconds no time and no Pawn
that's a little bit too much
the good thing is black has great
centralization here the black Bishop
will be able to uh stop the white a pawn
from running Black's King can start
jumping in at some point can start
entering now and uh okay there we go the
black king is in Suddenly It's a three
result game but uh white apron can that
one do the damage Anish setting up some
nasty night Forks
that white knight coming round to defend
everything but well white should be
winning but there's a big question
whether four minutes four seconds on the
clock will he be able to Queen the pawn
over there in Knight C6 is coming
winning the bishop
and surely the Knight is going to
sacrifice itself for the B Pawn and the
white king will seal all the glory and
go for the remaining Pawn on F5 white
has to bring back the Knight yep
what is he going to bring it to Niche
Gary He's got only a few seconds left
he's brought it back in line now with
that black b-pawn but can white Force
The Exchange the two remaining F bonds
will decide the game who gets there
first later
oh Black's King's coming back this
surely isn't a good sign for Magnus
Carlson but oh maybe he's saving it what
is saving well it's a fair result but
with a roller coaster in between
yeah we saw the evaluation bar white was
winning but such a tricky endgame and
Magnus working his in-game magic to hold
the draw Let's uh zoom out now to the
bird's eye view we have all the results
of the games well we didn't expect it to
be this dramatic so early in the day
that that fell so quick actually it
feels like we've only been there for two
minutes and somehow it is over for round
one so let's take a look at the round
one scores in fact it was a draw between
Anish giri and Magnus Carlson and it was
also a draw between Wesley so and Hikaru
Nakamura and meanwhile alireza farouza
did defeat Ari antari and gukash
celebrating his birthday well it didn't
bring him any birthday luck in the first
round because he lost to Fabiana caruana
and shakurai out Mama jarov draw against
Nordic Abdul sirf well what a start to
the Norway chess Blitz event
yeah and uh maybe we can go and check
out some of the games and uh some of the
action in those Blitz Games we weren't
able to cover and uh one of the games
that caught my eye in the first round
was that win by alireza farouza against
Ariane tari and uh we
yeah we know that uh of course it's
early days it's nine rounds but uh yeah
those players who started with a win
they will be aiming to win the
tournament now well and it's a very
important part right to win the first
game it always gives you a good mood
good energy and then you think okay the
next one I also want to win
and then maybe you win all the games
because things are going so fast in a
blitz tournament but definitely this
game what we just looked at it was uh
quite nerve-wracking for the players I
believe but the problem the others were
also quite something saying the final
positions of the others yes uh certainly
and I I have to say do any of you still
feel like first round nerves because
often it's sad that you know you start a
tournament you don't know how it's gonna
go you're sitting there and it'll hit
you and you just need a you know two
three games just to warm yourself up oh
absolutely you need a warm-up period And
this is great for the players whatever
happens if you win the blitz tournament
probably say okay I'm the best if you go
wrong and things go badly oh this was
just a drawing of lots kind of story
yeah and uh talking of some of the
highlights from round one this is the
finish of the game between alarism and
ariantari we do see that a question mark
on the last move by white bringing up
the Rook to C7 from farrusia he was
actually in trouble if Aryan had brought
his Knight to the center of the board
black is a pawn up and would had great
winning chances but just to show the
final few moves of this game black gave
a check with his rook and things started
to go wrong simply the White Knight
entered the position and suddenly
ferrugia working his magic gotta pass
pawn and was able to promote look at
this just the last few moves the pawn
simply ran through and with no time on
the clock Aryan Harriet was not able to
stop this Pawn The Rook threatens to
jump out the way with the check with a
promotion and after Knight takes F3 that
did indeed happen Rook check the White
Queen appeared on the board and that was
the end of the game such a dramatic
turnaround and that's gonna happen a lot
in Blitz it's not enough to get a better
position or a winning position you have
to win it there's a huge difference
between collecting the full point or
just to have an Inquisition especially
if it's such a short time control what
we had yeah certainly I agree with you
it's all about keeping control of your
nerves and also the clock I mean they do
say that when you're playing Blitz that
the clock is your 17th piece hang on
have I got that right 19th
I'm very bad with maths
yes 17th piece I believe that Ivanka and
uh just to show one more quick highlight
uh of the first round we saw a big game
between birthday boy kukesh and Fabiano
caruana and this if we can pull it up
was the final position we did see the
white king just park itself on H2 and
the players did agree to a draw because
black could simply repeat the queen hits
the king check white steps back and
there's no way to escape the Perpetual
here Queen to C1 white Cannot drop back
and block because this bishop would fall
so kukesh having had a great position
earlier in the game wasn't able to win
this one at a solid start for both
players in the first round after a
repetition of checks here
yeah and well
doesn't actually have too much time to
recover they will get a few minutes and
then back to the action and what a what
a start already I just feel like it's
opened with some fireworks already
and let's have a look at the standings
and there we can see alireza farouza one
point uh and also Magnus Carlson has got
one point and
uh fabiani carono has one point and
Magnus Carlson Half Point Hikaru
Nakamura also half point so everything
to play for
yep everything to play for and uh okay
this remember is the blitz event and I
think we'll just correct those uh some
of those results in a moment but
um this is just the blitz event the
players are playing for seeding but do
you think we saw that kind of reflected
in the last game Magnus taking huge
risks in an equine game just to try and
win uh against this rival win actually
objectively it was a draw well we can
say that he he thinks that he can he can
do anything he think he's right
the first impression that okay it's a
place tournament I try everything I want
to win even the completely dead drawish
end game right and when it was like B4
he played I had this feeling Oh What A C
first there for the night right and well
of course he's able to pull out his
magical hand after having blundered or
something like that and this is what
happened right here right now but isn't
it a way of asserting dominance when you
manage to save what is objectively a
lost position it's going to fire black
very easily exactly right but I mean I
mean even if you get a lost position and
you say to your opponent hey I'm still
good enough to draw it or you're not
good enough to win it to be honest
actually I was very surprised that Anish
could not convert it because if it would
be not Magnus sitting opposite but let's
say a 2500 player like who is much lower
in rating then it wouldn't be a problem
but somehow Magnus is sitting there and
a piece up is not enough right
we're sitting opposite me and ishigiri
he would have crushed me 100 times out
of 100 from that piece of end game but
yeah like but also Magnus kind of makes
his moves like I still have a chance I'm
fighting for it right body language and
and also of course it's more than that
it's not only luck but he he knows the
potential opportunities and of course
bringing his King back this was the only
opportunity somehow to catch on the
Knight and the opponent and get back and
talking about round one that's been gone
we now do have to look ahead to the
round two match-ups and we are gonna see
a lot of exciting games in stuff and we
see Magnus Carlson facing off against 17
year old gukesh Hikari Nakamura gets
abdusator Fabiana caruana Marv madorov
ariantari with the white pieces against
Anish giri and now it's Wesley so's turn
to face off against alireza faruga and
Judith
which match excites you the most I'm
very curious how they both players will
continue Anish and Magnus and of course
Magnus against gokash I'm very excited
on that game because let's see how they
recover and they go on with the next
round
and David which one do you want to keep
your eyes on yeah we're spoiled for
Choice that's the problem all these
matchups I'm gonna say Hikaru Nakamura
against notibec Abdul sotorov I think
Hikaru if he does get on a roll he is
the type of kind of streaky form player
especially in Blitz he can just crush
the field but he needs to get motoring
and if he wins this next round Hikaru I
think he might be one of the favorites
and there we do see the players sitting
down at the board Abdul sotorov a man in
form winner of the chess kid cup former
World rapper Champion can he translate
that to Blitz and I think we will be
starting with this one hey Carlos Focus
Judith
well it's going to be a very exciting
game I believe because Nakamura is a
great Blitz player right and of course
the youngsters are always playing great
I believe uh I played a lot of Blitz
myself I was a huge Blitz player but I
think this new generation is really
playing online they are used to the fact
that it's not only the classical event
there are a lot of Rapid events a lot of
playoffs a lot of Armageddon so with all
these time controls they have to be
ready at the same time they have their
very sharp mind and they can stand the
the stressful moments very well but I'm
not afraid that Nakamura will give his
uh his skin so easily
yeah you talk about the Young Generation
being very experienced online there's
nobody more experienced online than
hikar Nakamura and we are off it's uh an
early start here Queen's Pawn opening
and wow the bishop coming out to G5
early in the game Hikaru Nakamura really
trying to land that surprise effect with
this opening and uh well Abdus tour of
he's got his openings worked out so he
actually jumps forward with his Knight
and now challenges the pawn in in the
middle of the board and we also have to
remember when it comes Hikaru he's not
just also a full-time streamer he is
actually number two Blitz player in the
world
and number one bits player in the world
is actually well in terms of ratings
it's not actually Magnus Carlsen it's
alireza farusia with a rating of 29.04 I
think in the live ratings but I think
he's someone who plays a lot of bullets
as well online yeah those things I never
played for example so they are so Speedy
players
yeah Speedy players and the first time
we've seen the players pause is after
Black's Bishop has just landed on G4 a
bit of an annoying pin here for Nakamura
to deal with he's just taking a moment
or two uh in normally in this type of
Pawn structure you just want to cement a
Pawn on C3 you just want to build a
strong Pawn Center it looks like a
London system uh it has actually
transposed to almost a London system
here but uh yeah Nakamura deciding
whether to take a solid path or with it
whether to go maybe a bit more
aggressive I'm not sure what the options
would be here maybe you just kick away
the black Bishop uh with upon it's a H3
really long thing for Hikaru exactly
this is what I wanted to point out that
when you have three minutes you're not
spending 40 seconds on a move right
yeah it's that lack of confidence maybe
I think maybe it was he was just kind of
surprised that it actually he has to
make a decision because the D4 Pawn can
be vulnerable because of the pin but now
it will be a question whether what do
you think it's going to be long Castle
or short Castle in this game oh my let's
be cool he answers it for you but then
but then you have to kind of ask this
question like what is White's Advantage
because to me okay well I wasn't
expecting the bishop to trade itself for
the Knight but the structure is very
stable black doesn't have a problem in
development
very stable position and it's also a big
question always how can you play an
opening in Blitz which is easier to play
because that's very important that you
can just flesh out the moves and it's
just a very natural plan of course C4 is
very logical this is the only way black
can be challenged I believe I wonder
after DTX C4 whether D5 and somehow
white wants to put pressure on the King
on E8 so not allowing to castle that's
the only thing what
Nakamura can have in mind and then Blitz
it's a very strong move I believe yeah
it's really instructive White's Bishop
power was about to be eliminated but
it's all about speed and like you say
the black king was about to come under
Fire in the center so not a bet castles
I think a good practical decision for
black but not there to take on C4
because he was afraid that it will open
up very much for the king so he went for
a very solid symmetrical game right
white is going to be a little bit
pushing baby Rook to C1 Rook to E1
controlling the files
but uh
ignore the exchange of Bishops yeah he
covered I think like a lot of top Grand
Masters these days they are biased
towards the bishop pair and I love this
decision he's just putting pressure on
D5 he's saying okay long term black
under some pressure at the same time I
can't say that the E3 Bishop is doing so
much it became kind of passive after
this move and the D6 Bishop is very
active it's excellently placed right but
the question is how black is going to be
regrouping his pieces in D7 or is he
going to play Knight E7 to defend the D5
Pawn or he's just bringing his Rooks to
the open fire right now
yeah yeah
an interesting as well how white can
maximize that light squared Bishop I
mean is Hikaru just looking at doing
things small things like pushing a pawn
in front of the king just to maximize
the space there or is he gonna try to
actually control some of the dark
squares like C5 and E5 I like a lot this
last move by Nakamura because he's
controlling the F5 Square which I think
can be very important for the black
queen if maybe even in the previous move
Queen F5 was a better move to control
those white squares because for the
moment these divide squares I like very
much for white even when B5 can be
something to think of for y to put
pressure on B7 and the D5 Pawn
and and also G3 what you you mentioned
are like also very much G3 King G2 so it
also A3 to stop the Knight B4 option
then improve the Rooks position from F1
maybe doubling on the C file but it's
maneuvering
the next part of the game it definitely
feels like the players are jockeying for
position but it's black who's kind of
lacking a productive plan uh just to
point out as well Bishop takes Pawn was
maybe threatened on that last move it
wasn't earlier because the black Bishop
could have taken on H2 getting out the
way and the bishop on D5 would have been
attacked for white uh so therefore I've
just sort of drops back and uh nicely
defended this Pawn but very passive move
yeah now black is trying to get the
bishop to G7 and put pressure on the D4
Pawn I believe
I like very much h4h5 later on King G2
Rook H1 will appear on the H file I
think just in case to put a little
pressure there yeah and well now uh
Hikari actually had to answer a question
of why to put the queen and I must admit
I did not anticipate this queen move I
thought the queen was slide two squares
to B3 it can be very far away to be
honest because now Queen on H3 white
didn't have time to play King G2 which
is an important part I think Rook C3
against capturing Rook E3 was something
a threat by black and I'm not sure white
is so happy right now
the queen
of course
he was not the world rapid 2021 Champion
for nothing he spots that and Retreats
the queen and well you you've kind of
highlighted this move many many moves
ago the king will step up and now the
white Rook is going to slide over to the
H line and it's such an instructive game
I feel from Hikaru side it's interesting
that Rook C5 I'm not sure it's
necessarily the best move but it's kind
of an unpleasant move right and maybe
he's also testing the opponent are you
one do you want to go back bishop f8 and
making a repetition of moves are you
playing for a draw just a little testing
the opponent and but at the same time
the D4 Pawn is not uh vulnerable what do
you think yeah it seems so looks like
there are going to be some tactics white
can capture the black pawn in the center
and uh it might come at the cost of his
own D4 Pawn but first Hikaru trades will
the two Bishops be decisive I think
that's the big question that's going to
be the only imbalance once black grabs
on D4 this Pawn also hanging do you get
greedy and take it it feels like Black's
very active but uh Hikaru he knows how
to quell any activity and wow okay big
threat don't forget about your Rook on
E8 just a typical Blitz move there
you're just creating some small threats
and maybe going after this A7 Pawn as
well well I believe Rook d8 is something
to play but black wanted to defend the
B7 I'm not sure it was the the best
opportunity now the Bishops are very
powerful and the a pawn has fallen off
the board and for me who likes to grab
pawns that is very good news indeed and
but there is some problem maybe for
black he cannot go to the H file because
of the another important stuff has
fallen off the board and Hikaru just
giving checks and take a look at
nordeback's clock time just one second
oof who made that move with two seconds
to spare yeah only two second increments
it's not a lot of time for the players
and I think that's a short sequence
where Abdul sarov was down to five
seconds it's going to decide the game
two pawns up now okay down to one point
one of them one of them has dropped but
that white a pawn is going to be
decisive oh Bishop D6 some tactical
issues over there yeah there's still
some checks though and also
okay he centralizes The Rook oh but an
order back he is showing what a fighter
he is he's managed to trade off queens
and still one Pawn deficit what do you
think
on the a file it can go only one by one
but eventually it will reach possibly
destination it's aiming for yeah that
white apron will cost black it uh his
Bishop here and what amazing what
do right
I'm in Queen A4 I think Queen A4 was the
move for the confusion and we see a
result and Nordic has resigned and
Hikari walks away with the point what a
game from Hikaru I thought it was very
instructive yes just typical Hikaru he
didn't do anything too flashy no big
tactics just experience yeah experience
experience accumulating the small
advantages and converting them
eventually and putting pressure on the
opponent and asking question what do you
do here how do you regroup your pieces
where do you maneuvering your Bishop
where do you put your knight but you
have a lot of other interesting games
running and let's go to the Magnus game
against birthday boy gukesh it's a very
tense end game Magnus he seems to thrive
in these types of positions but okay
everything still to play for it's really
unbalanced lots of passports all over
the place who's better here and why the
evaluation Bar says equal but it looks
anything but drawn to me
oh there is a B2 Pawn wow that is
something to be annoying but right now
white is collecting some of the
important most important bones
yeah black is grabbing some pawns too
some counter play potentially on the
king side Knight H4 Knight F3 exactly
one Knight F3 absolutely has a Target
but I mean let's not forget that two
players playing that game and white
Central pawns are just racing up the
board
um it's a race race wow We're Off to the
Races as they say and uh meanwhile we
also see a result Carolina did lose to
Mama jarov
yeah big uh big results here in the
standings we'll go and recap the results
a bit later on but this race it feels
like white has to start running the king
towards the Black Knight and pawns well
the H2 Pawn will be grabbed
yeah and in Practical terms it feels
easier to play Black it's just one track
mind just push the pawns go for glorion
whoa looks like a blunder from Magnus
Carlsen is black going with one oops
well it's a nice birthday present but
Magnus will not give up well I guess he
I think it will take
the night
I think a transmission error here he did
take that black knight the game goes on
we can see in the video they're playing
moves here very very fast but queen
against Knight and two points should be
easy to convert dude well I'm not sure
it's so easy even obviously Magnus has
his incredible skills of defense and the
Knight on F3 is standing great
protecting the pawn on E5 so the
question is whether the black king is
able to come out to C6 and D5 and
somehow push back a little bit the
Knight and the king at the same time so
I think really King C6 should be the
move eventually yeah only a few seconds
for go cash though can the birthday
oh and uh and of course there is always
a problem with blunders there is always
an opportunity to blunder
and look how active the pieces are and
right oh
feel the nerves the pawns are pushing is
Magnus gonna turn this one around how am
I around
horns have been stopped and uh Magnus
with just 40. there is such an easy to
blunder some Knight C6 check eventually
laughing
[Music]
well what can you do though when you
make a mistake like that smile I'm not
sure I'm not sure it was winning at the
end I think if he doesn't blunder pushes
his spawn I think with the King
defending the Knight the Knight
defending the pawn the pawn defending
the other phone the black king is stuck
there and maybe it's a interpositional
draw
yeah it feels like Magnus had fought
back but in the end blundering one of
his pawns away resigning against
anything can happen in the Blitz and we
should mention Magnus Carlson hasn't won
the blitz section of Norway chess since
2017. I see that all the games were
decisive and uh let's take a recap of
round two we saw Magnus Carlson just
losing there to 17 year old kakesh
Hikaru Nakamura played a smooth game
against Abdus Fabiana karona did lose to
Shakura mamajov and aryantari well his
woes continued as he lost to Anish giri
and Wesley so picking up a victory
against world number one rated in Blitz
alireza farouza
well what a decisive round wow it's to
be expected when you're playing Blitz
it's blast is furious but you can see
that Magnus is somehow Rusty I think in
this these first two games you could see
that he couldn't uh
sense it feel it exactly what are the
borders
yeah somehow he sensed that he was
pushing his luck yeah and he he took it
get too far but you know they do say
that Magnus is very slow starter well
not very slow but the slow starter in
general warms up and then just gets
motoring and yeah one player who isn't a
slow starter is Wesley so and this is
how he won his game against alireza
faruja in round two of the blitz
tournament to me it looks almost equal
this position level pawns level pieces
but Wesley has the advantage because his
Knight is actually extremely active here
there's a big Target on the A5 Square
the white king is marching into the
center and just to show the great end
game technique with which Wesley
converted this Advantage after black
played E5 he simply stepped forward
sorry yeah Pawn on the dark Square yeah
like that and after Knight to F6 simply
a pawn dropped Bishop takes A5 and just
as we saw in the Magnus Carlson game
Knights are incredibly bad at stopping
Rooks pawns this white a pawn was ready
to race forward black could not go for
the bishop trade therefore and uh a
couple moves later sorry Bishop to E5 98
and it was just one more move I think
and the game was decided a few turns
later white simply
plant one we should remember that that
Bishop on B6 is just so supportive of
the a pawn is just protecting the A5
square is important A7 is so important
and uh yeah the black bone on C5 and the
weakness on e4 well that was a quite
unfortunate finish for uh firoza yeah
it's extraordinary we had the same
pattern in two games uh we had it in
Hikaru Nakamura against nordeback and
now we saw it here just to demonstrate
its venomous capabilities and
once once these games kick off it just
feels like it's all Non-Stop and I see
that there were some funny endings on
Queen and Bone queen against Rook so
they really played out all the way and
of course when you have only seconds
left it's so difficult to recall any
theoretical drawing moves or winning so
it really matters a lot in what state of
mind you are playing today in just these
two three hours of the Blitz tournament
which is running
so exciting and games yeah and talking
of exciting end games I want to show you
both uh just one fascinating finish and
in Blitz anything can happen but this
one had a few twists and turns it's a
rook end game White currently are Pawn
down but he equalized the material by
calculating a long variation he grabbed
this Pawn heading into a king of Paul
nine game deflecting the black king from
its rook and suddenly the race began the
king G4 white started running towards
the black pawns and as we saw in this
race actually it feels like this one
should be a draw if white was accurate
but Pawn to B5 a big blunder he should
have actually pushed the a pawn and uh
Queens as soon as black Queen's the pawn
White's a pawn would be far enough down
the board to hold the draw instead
Fabiano a bit of a slip here pushing the
wrong pawn and uh as we saw black was
first to make a queen and b-pawns are
not good against Queens in the same game
even though if you have two of them yeah
even if you have two of them exactly
Judah it took a few moves but uh black
was able to round up the point it seems
like it's not a blister government only
but it's a race tournament as well of
Bones
wow
it's a it's a nice uh thing to see and
we do need to look at the blitz
standings after two rounds and well
we're gonna see at the top of the table
it is Hikaru Nakamura with one and a
half points out of two and running
alongside him are Anish giri and Wesley
so and chakra out mamajov and we have
some people on 50 alireza Fabiano gukash
and Magnus on half point out of two and
David are you surprised by these
standings so far I mean it's early days
it's early days I'm most surprised I've
got to admit by Magnus because yes he
often is a slow starter but just last
week he won an extremely strong over the
board Blitz tournament that being said
he's only one point behind the lead and
with seven Blitz game still to go
anything can happen I've got to say
extremely impressed so far by anishagiri
and of course Hikaru Nakamura just
experience shining through
certainly experience shining through and
it's going to be such an exciting event
and of course you have to remember
remind ourselves that this blitz event
stands as a precursor to the classical
event and whoever finishes first will
get to pick their seatings and the top
five seedings will have that extra white
with the classical games and how
important is that classic that extra
white I think the players are not
thinking about that at all but of course
they are going to be much more happy to
have the extra point just in case
and let's remind ourselves of the round
three match-ups and there again we have
more thrilling experings we have chakra
mamajarov now facing off against Magnus
Carlson chakra one of the most creative
Grandmasters around alireza farooza
playing against Hikaru and Nakamura now
these two are big rivals on the blitz
rating list and then we have Anish giri
against Wesley so gukash against Ariane
and norderbeck against Fabiano Carona
and I have to ask you Judith which
pairing would are you most excited about
well now it's alireza Nakamura
absolutely
I really want to see what's going to
happen over there because it was some
magic with Hikaru just did in the
previous game he really showed his class
and his experience and he just won a
move with two moves and he turned
everything around but it was already
something for a second for of the sator
of that okay finally it's draw let's
exchange everything and and then that
second he fell apart yeah suddenly and
David are you equally excited by this
encounter yes for sure we saw the
handshake there Hikaru means business uh
often it is about how you start in the
tournament and as I mentioned earlier
Hikaru who's the type of player who can
get on a roll but uh farouza of course
will be aiming to attack the white
pieces for him I think are actually
essential not just in the blitz
tournament but the classical he's so
strong with white every time I see
farrugia play so uh Hikaru here I think
he'll be happy to just get out of the
opening with a solid position actually
looking for a relaxed Hikaru his thing
he loves to play Blitz and of course he
loves to win which he did just in a
previous round but you don't see him
nervous did you ever see him really
nervous I mean look at his focused
concentrated and he wants to win yeah
and the handshake and the players are
off and far Asia opening with the King's
Pawn and will Hikaru employ his
trademark Berlin oh yeah I had the
boring one I'm very happy to see there's
no 13 move repetition there yeah going
against her or maybe what some people
were fearing at home I know here in the
studio we thought oh Berlin not a good
sign for a fighting game but this one is
very tense most pieces still on the
board only a trade of one set of Pawns
so far and if I recall correctly for
Russia has been employing this opening
or this specific variation against the
Berlin a lot in recent times so has
Hikaru done his homework looks very
symmetrical to it it is very symmetrical
and the bishop and C5 is extremely
powerful now Knight B8 is something a
nice regrouping of the night eventually
it wants to go to D7 after C6 or without
C6 Brooke goes from fa to E8 or d8
Knight f8 Knight G6 or E6 possibly but
also it was important for black I guess
to go away from the Bishop from B5 to B
exchanged and it's very typical what
white is going to Knight F1 also trying
to get to G3 possibly to F5
uh it's important for black that he
played A5 so B4 gaining space is not
possible for from right side now I would
think Bishop G4 I would uh like to play
it with black what is white pinning
their hopes on for
because uh to my mind I know I'm not so
experienced with these type of positions
it just looks equal I mean okay let's
once black has come to completed their
development and uh there we can see the
Knight is actually targeting the F2 pawn
and well
a Hikaru is just initiating a set of
traits your cover is so good in these
types of positions I've got to say even
when it looks like there's nothing going
on he's so good at just sensing the
tempo I was fearful for black I thought
symmetrical but white is two or three
moves ahead suddenly black starts the
attack attacking this uh F2 Pawn he gets
time to develop his Bishop there's going
to be a bishop trade and no problems at
all that I foresee for black here
well anything can happen in these
positions I believe white is going to be
exchanging on E6 then he goes H3 then he
comes with the Knight to E3 I believe or
well without the H3 but F5 Square it
don't underestimate it from White side I
like to have my knight on F5 in this
kind of structures eventually it's going
to play B3 Bishop B2 or Bishop B2 and B4
bringing the other Rook
uh it's a slow maneuvering part of
course in these positions that these
three Square can be vulnerable and
weakness for white so it will be
interesting how black will develop the
knight from B8
through D7 to whether he's going to be
moving away the bishop and to locate the
Knight on C5 but the Knight is on F5 and
the H6 spawn can be captured sacrificed
by the bishop sometimes
and there we can see Hikari actually
preempting any sacrifices on H6 by
dropping the bishop back um perhaps the
Knight that no doesn't have a good home
on B8 will find its way on C5
well definitely I'd be D7 will be the
next move I believe because Bishop B6
can be yeah it's a bit annoying
yeah he's pausing here Hikaru like you
say just developed the piece maybe he's
also thinking about whether to at some
point move the king across and just
evict this knight from the square uh
Ivanka nice we started this rhyme and
Knight and F5 will Thrive and hear the
Knight on F5 the most important piece if
you kick it back I think black is okay
well of course King H7 and G6 is a is a
very sensible idea to kick out the F5
Knight but sometimes people are not
worried that much about their five night
it's more for the eye than it's in
reality some really big harm can be done
the question is whether can white go G4
and G5 for example it's especially Blitz
game kind of moves that you can go on
the nerves of your opponent and show
that you have some great ideas and
stabilize the Knight on F5 and it's not
really opening too much the king size
for the white so I'm a big G4 fan so I
would definitely probably try out at
some point you predicted it yeah G4
it's on the board big attack incoming
for white risky because White's King is
open you lose control over some key
squares later on but we love to see it I
was about to say as well it's alois's
style to attack I think when he goes for
slower maneuvering games he's less
strong so yes he's had to drop back with
his Knight and F5 but the pawn is going
to step forward even further Line's
about to become open around the black
king well I'm worried a little bit for
white with the if black can go reach to
D3 with the Knight and even double
Bishop D7 Rook uh d8 also Queen exchange
offer is something very unpleasant for
white
so let's see but can't I take a pawn
with Bishop C5 exchange and then take on
E5
yeah you can
yeah tactics are about to happen I think
you might go for that Judith the
evaluation bar doesn't react so we see
it's still probably five for black but
hikara must have had to do some
calculation uh when going for this
variation if you don't take this Knight
first if you first capture on E5 then
later after a queen trade the white E4
Pawn will drop so yeah it looks like if
you want to win this game this is what
you have to go for well I think black is
going to capture back somehow gaining
the E4 Pawn so it's going to be open
file D file and E file Knight E5 is
another way he wanted to keep his Bishop
which is also understandable he wants to
have his Bishop on B6 or potentially
eventually it's roughly an equal
position I believe but and G4 is not
doing any harm to White in an end game
at all yeah actually it's quite nice to
have this Square for your king it's
quite nice to kind of clamp down on
black spawns on Dart squares watch out
for any end game favoring white if it
just comes down to Bishops because
White's Bishop more active than its
counterparts so still very level and the
players have three to draw as easy as
that I mean we were discussing all the
subtleties and the players like yeah
let's call it a day let's uh move on to
the next round and whoa it was quite a
tense struggle I would say and do you
think both of these players would have
looked at the opponents and gone I'm
gonna Target you and I'm going to give a
draw against you I'm not that fast
it depends very much on the tournament
situation but at the same time of course
the players don't want to give out all
their energy today because tomorrow the
real stuff starts right today is the fun
fun part of the tournament really that
they can try out everything anything
they want because they want to focus
obviously for tomorrow but of course
they don't want to give points just like
that but look at that Magnus is in
trouble again Magnus Carlson he lost
round two he's about to fall to defeat
in round three if and it's a big if
shakirak manager can hold his nerve
white here is a pawn up looks like a
very dangerous passport as well and if
white can somehow bring his Knight into
the game I'm not sure which kind of
Route you take into the position the
black king looks weaker than its rival
there we go the White Knight is in Black
needs counter play Black needs to get
his pieces towards the white king I
don't see it right now in Magnus on the
run with his King but simply step
forward with your Pawn but what about G6
Knight D5 against shark we are not
getting away with this yeah shuck is so
good with white he's so good when he's
got the initiative and he had no risk
either and White's about to make a new
Queen after a queen check push G7 G8
it's coming through and it's it's a
beautiful move for a shark because that
Queen on h8 controls a lot of the dark
squares around the white king and yep we
have seen a result Magnus does indeed
resign and Shaq moves to two and a half
points out of three
um what a stop by the world well not
world champion former world champion
yeah it feels like he's just taking too
many risks at these early stages magnets
of course hates to draw he wants to win
every game but that can backfire when
you're playing against such uh such
strong opponents yeah well done to Shack
though nice Victory from him
but he's a fantastic Blitz player a
fantastic player and the great Blitz
player himself and of course
for Magnus it it was a very shaky start
and it seems like he he did not found
his uh his form yet
not yet he needs to work his way but one
game still remaining and that is between
nordeback and Fabiano
yeah nodded back here in huge trouble
look at the white king that white king
is uh gonna have some serious issues in
the near future first a night trade is
Fabiano may be messing it up though wow
without the knights he can't deliver
Checkmate and the black G Pawn has
dropped I thought that pawn was going to
decide the game suddenly the tables have
turned and white is a pawn up in this
end game still open Kings though with
Queens on the board Anything Can Happen
Judah oh absolutely just seeing this few
seconds what was going on in the last
few moves and I would still bet on a
draw looking these kind of moves that
it's going to be some Rook end game at
the end and the a pawn will be pushed
actually now I don't know which king is
more vulnerable the white or the black
now white can blunder something but Rook
a one and quick well it's getting shaky
for white yeah certainly and that's why
Nordic actually moves his Queen to the
aid of the white king
it's it feels like there's a lot of
checks and they're just making those
moves just to build up that time because
they do get an extra two seconds on the
clock per move and Nordic now doing
great things you know centralizing the
queen white king pretty safe and queen
is targeting the C5 Pawn what's happened
I think lost on somebody lost on time
wow we have a result where are The Kinks
looks like fabby's clock ran out
difficult position he was facing a
difficult defense there but Abdul
satorophy up takes the win in a rematch
I should mention of the final of the
chess kick up Abdul sator of triumphs
again over Fabi well this was a very
painful loss what we've seen he had
completely winning position Pawn on G to
front of the white king Knight on E5
the doubling The Rook the queen
everything and then two moves it's the
G2 Pawn just is gone so this will be
something to to get hard to get overcome
on that for Fabio I think yeah it is a
little bit tough and uh here we can look
at the round three scores it was a great
round for Shakura mamajorf as he took
down Magnus Carlsen draw between Ali
Raza farisa and Hikaru Nakamura Anish
Geary also played a draw against Wesley
so and good cash lost against Aryan
Atari much needed point for Aryan there
and nordebec when it beating Fabiano
caruana once more
well what a start three rounds in and
we've seen surprises we've seen tense
moments and we just saw some Fabi lose
on time and well I think we have a lot
of things
oh it's it's amazing so I'm really
really really interesting stuff going on
maybe Nakamura we can say he's
incredibly stable the game itself very
stable logical no big blunders or
anything like that yeah as you say he's
just doing his thing Hikaru Nakamura but
we do have a different leader at the
moment after three games if we look at
the blitz standings it's actually the uh
the winner against Magnus Carlsen it's
the guy who took down the king Shakura
mamajorov storming out to the lead in uh
after three rounds two and a half points
and he is followed by three players
hikaranakamura anishikiri and Wesley so
yeah you've got to say some players have
been more stable than others at this
early stage and I think that's reflected
in the standings it's certainly early
days though we're still plenty of rounds
left so anything can happen but I agree
with David a promising start for
shakuria mamajarov and what do you think
Jude did
well seeing the cross table is quite
scary Magnus is number 10. this is not
something I'm used to or anybody I think
I think we are going to see some great
fights in the next round absolutely I'm
expecting some magic and also from my by
Magnus yeah and uh talking about great
fights we've seen a lot of great fights
in round three but before we head into a
break for round four we have to say
don't miss your chance to win a diamond
membership this Friday the chess.com
Discord server is hosting an arena with
four Diamond memberships up for grabs to
stake your claim join the Discord at
go.chess.com forward slash Discord then
connect your account to chess.com and
you're done you can now compete in the
weekly arena for our Discord community
and win free Diamond membership use x
Glam Discord in chat now oh and talking
about Diamond play I'm we do have to say
that they're seeing a lot of tense
moments a lot of struggles and we are
gonna catch our breaths as we go into a
break for round four so join us on the
other side
foreign
[Music]
next year
oh my goodness Knight d8 whoa fantastic
keep holding me chance work F7 oh no
no
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
action as the chess excitement continues
in Stavanger and we are going to dive
straight into the round four match-ups
and once again and I keep saying this we
are in for a treat because we have the
world's best players competing here in
OHS we have Magnus Carlson against
noribbeck Abdus Magnus starting off with
half a point out of three Hikaru
Nakamura against Fabiano caruana
ariantari against Shakira mamajarov
Wesley so against kukash alireza against
Anish giri and Judy which which matchup
really excites you well I don't know
kind of all of them but I'm very curious
about Hikaru and Furby game but also
what Magnus has to do with the with the
youngster
yeah and there we can see the two
players are lined up in fact they're
making their moves David what do we have
in store for us yep we have started in
this clash between Nakamura and karawana
it looks like uh Nakamura is deploying
the same opening we saw him use earlier
in the day when he took down Abdul
sotorov but can karwana do any better
recovering of course from the game just
before the break where he ended up
losing on time always a blow to the
confidence and early days it looks
almost symmetrical uh still very quiet
position it looks like that's the
strategy Nakamura has chosen at this
early stage it's very interesting that
he decided to go extremely solid right
that he wants to put the pieces very
quickly he has his strategy and then
somehow in the middle game he will
Shuffle things the way that confuse the
opponent and maybe goes wrong gaining
time
and the C4 of course is the move to open
up the position and try to play for more
than just a very English position right
but black has all the thing to equalize
there is no problem with the bishop it's
an F5 it's out so it's the bishop the
opponent E6 is not blocking it so it is
clearly who has better nerves who is
more focused concentrated will win this
game yeah I've got to admit if it was me
playing this position with white I think
all of the top players would criticize
me for playing for a draw but uh Hikaru
is getting away with it and uh if he can
squeeze water out of this Stone it looks
totally level to me then uh yeah fair
play to him I have to say I actually
really like what hikari's done I know
it's just it's very subtle but I feel
that that niggle that he will get with a
knight perhaps coming to A4 and C5 is
going to be enough just to put Fabiana
under pressure and there we see Hikaru
is simply lining his forces up on the
c-line
I think it's also kind of a provocation
that I don't want too much I'm just
making moves I don't want really
advantage
show me do you want to beat me punch me
you know and and I mean look at the
position it's practically nothing for
white and black angle Bishop H5 or he
can also try to go Knight A5 Knight C4 I
mean there's so many plans for black as
well right that you have to choose you
have to spend a little few seconds here
a few seconds there well if he doesn't
have any advantage with white I might as
well play for a win right but if you try
to play for a win with black it's not so
easy to get really something but I like
Bishop H5 and queen F6 and somehow in
the queen I think it's kind of
unpleasant for white yeah unpleasant and
actually in terms of clock times Hikaru
is down by 30 seconds he's hinting that
he might push the pawn to G4 to kick
away books Bishop but uh that will he
really do that he's hinting that's what
I think Hikaru does I believe that it's
a kind of a panic move also that if I
have to avoiding losing any material or
whatever I'm going to play G4 or when
you're going to have 20 seconds on your
clock I'm going to play before
I think though
um Fabi will have to consider at every
move and it will cost him maybe two
seconds you know that that I think he's
waiting for it yeah he's waiting for it
the weaken the white king it's uh
actually I'm not even sure he's not
going to play F5 at some point
oh you stop G4 and also to try to play
possibly sometimes well the center is
very stable for black do you think black
can go follow through with after F5 with
G5 you never know Special Olympics but
Knight B1 I think is a smart move to
strengthen the Knight on F3 and to
relieve the queen from E2
and also to open up the line for the
Rook but I prefer to play it with black
and big threats on the board black was
threatening to take a pawn in the center
hitting the White Queen and opening up
some tactics along the file so White's
Queen has dropped back Hikaru is in
defensive mode I've got to say I think
the opening was not a success at all but
uh he is still Rock Solid Hikaru
Nakamura can he turn things around I
just love what fabi's been doing and
also he's been doing it quickly Fabi
still up 30 seconds on the clock is
black but the next few moves might be
decisive in terms of the kind of
narrative of this game now fabi's opened
up those Rooks on the C file some Mass
exchanges some Mass trades black can
still maybe occupy the sea file if uh if
black white does trade now I believe G4
Knight E5 can happen actually because
Knight on E5 gives a great opportunity
for white
and centralized the night of course I'm
not very happy that white exchange The
Rook on C on the C file because C file
is extremely important that's the only
open file right so if black can control
that and keep control over there that's
the only way black can get better
yep and uh we'll take a look I mean he's
inviting black to actually put the queen
on C2 attacking The Rook as David said
but one thing we have seen time and time
again from Hikaru as we also see our
chat mentioned that Hikaru is incredibly
resourceful he gets into bad positions
he survives them he turns them around
and he's definitely one of the best
defenders in chess history I think
Ivanka especially in Rapid and Blitz
chess but look at what he's doing just
Quiet Moves getting the white Rook out
of the pin uh along this diagonal and
now what can Fabi make he's got the open
C file but he needs something a bit more
tangible at the Knight on E5 will show
up and that's something you rather you
prefer to avoid with black but I think
black cannot stop
strange move there from Fabi Queen to B7
looks a bit passive he wants to go A6 I
believe but I'm also thinking that it's
kind of slow and the Knight does appear
in the center of the board now humor me
guys how realistic is the threat of G2
G4 oh it's coming in the next move but I
think the last three moves there was a
huge uh shift in in this game
because white is not worse at all
white screen on B4 is just nice Knight
shows up when I fall shortly
what do you think trade those Knights
now does Hikaru have any more we talk
about the queen and Knight versus queen
and Bishop often favoring the queen and
Knight actually exchange on C4
and now black has to decide whether D
takes E4 now the structure is not simple
white can show up with the opponent E4
D5
and the pawn structure on the king side
with the G6 weakness it can be
vulnerable for black
for the first time in this game there's
a real imbalance and it's really not
clear who this favors in terms of clock
times it's still Fabby slightly ahead
but E4 is easier moves interesting move
because it stops b5a5 opportunity for
black at the same time it can also give
weaknesses for white Bishop E8 and
attack the A4 Pawn or regrouping the
bishop to D3 yeah and I like hikaru's
last moves you know just getting ready
as David indicated duplicate that porn
on C4 and maybe also jumping into F4
Bishop will Retreat or maybe it will
step forward
yeah some issues potentially along the C
file there's a pin we could white push
forward with B3 at some point isolate
Black's pawns over there uh Hikaru now
under 20 seconds Favi just over 20
seconds if it does come down to a Time
scramble I think Hikaru is a big
favorite if it's just a few seconds each
his instincts are so good in these
positions
and uh well talking about instincts
David what you predicted is actually
happening on the board the pawn has been
undermined and again this is risky for
Hikaru
extremely risky for both I would say yes
I I go in your direction then it's risky
for everybody but Knight on C3 it can be
regrouped to C3 F3 he's provoking wow I
think it favors white to have F3 yeah
black special could get locked out the
game if it retreats to a bad Square
white will start advancing forward in
the center a bit later on uh first that
white knight is gonna sit in front of
the black past Pawn that has to be plan
one from Hikaru Nakamura I believe the
bishop on H7 can
stop some of some of Black's important
squares for the king well big question
how for whites is how are they going to
handle this Pawn on D4 that's now Under
Fire it's seven seconds seven seconds
anti-carriage is calmly steps forward
and moves his King to defend the night
wow can you do that I thought he was
going to go Bishop takes Knight yeah
Fabi playing really ambitious chess
there he has to win yeah especially
after his last game I think he wants to
show it that he's back
too yeah the black Brook's coming in the
black queen is hitting some loose pawns
white king is more vulnerable than its
counterpart right now
clever here
oh he made that move with just a couple
of seconds left is it time to three
seconds into the second row what
happened I think we have a draw
agreement
wow Fabiano with the advantage but on
the clock really precarious stuff and
wow that shows how much respect they
have each other but for but also it
shows how much they both dislike their
positions crazy stuff I think black one
I think
wow
yes because why the nakamur lost on time
you'll see that once in a lifetime
Hikaru nakamur losing on time his
position was difficult but wow Judith a
shock yeah absolutely it was uh it was
very interesting for me how the opening
developed that uh Nakamura is playing so
solid and then suddenly something went
very wrong and I felt it that he was not
sure am I playing for a win do I what am
I playing for and you could see that the
bishop was always going back and forth
Bishop G6 Bishop F7 Bishop G6 Bishop D3
Bishop E4 Bishop F5 Bishop it was like a
touring of the bishop yeah I mean you're
right completely you know Hikaru just
went that you know just to salute just
to neutralize Fabiano and ended up being
indecisive and this his strategy just
did not work but uh whoa losing on time
though that does hurt and uh well I
think all the games have finished
and all decisive all decisive is there
any surprise there and I I think the big
news of the round is that Magnus Carlson
is finally back he's scored his first
win of the blitz tournament in round
four he's no longer in last place and
just to show how it happened against
Abdul satorov Magnus had outplayed him
white has the advantage here but uh this
clever move after the Black Knight
retreated Bishop to d8 in a new win yeah
a bit of a misstep there from Abdul
satorov Magnus won the Black rook and
went on to convert his material
advantage we expected it he was going to
come back sooner or later right yeah
that's always the case right
there's a few things that are certain in
life and that is one of them magnets
will always make a comeback he is the
master of doing that and well other
results it just seems like things have
gone in the expected ways we do see that
Mama jarov continuing his winning ways
beating Ari antari he's on fire
yeah continue to happen for him
he's that kind of guy who starts winning
and maybe he does not want to stop for
some time
he's also another one who would love an
extra white in the classical portion
absolutely absolutely and uh let's uh
work through the blitz standings after
round four and at the top of the table
after that Victory against Arya antari
it has to be shakuria mamajov very
impressive player and in second place
last year's winner of the blitz portion
is Wesley so Ali Reza farouza Hikaru
Nakamura two and a half and two points
respectively and Magnus Carlson there on
Seventh Place with his victory taking
him up to one and a half points out of
four oh what do you guys think about
that last round
well I think for Magnus for example it's
uh it somehow he he puts himself in a
very difficult position where everybody
thinks already that okay this is not his
day
and then from from the last place it is
nice to go forward and make progress and
eventually possibly win the tournament
even
but uh yeah then the Nakamura game was
also very interesting I haven't seen the
other ones but
yeah a lot of fire I mean you can see
that the players are really in the mood
to fight and they just give all in and
they don't have this pressure that
nothing gets take practically right so
they go out and they lose they win they
draw yeah it's not just that they want
to win there's also a lot of Nerfs I
must admit I've been watching Hikaru
nakamura's stream for years I've never
seen him lose on time ever and so to
lose on time even if his position was
difficult but he's not playing Fabian
Street
at least very rarely and maybe he's
extremely good in a mouse work right
sure very different over the board right
Ivanka yeah it is uh completely
different and over the board stuff uh on
chess and when it comes to predictions
can I be bold and ask you guys who do
you think you're gonna is gonna win
well it's kind of boring to say that
it's my major off right
well let's make a bet that Magnus wins
Magnus yeah if he wins all the game I
think it's still possible
even though he's two points behind the
lead right now
yeah I guess we're not even at halfway
in the blitz tournament still five
rounds to go uh I won't say Magnus I'll
say Wesley so just
I don't know I have a feeling just he's
so solid you'll never see him uh kind of
get too flustered and if the others do
start to go a bit up and down if Mama
jarov loses his hot streak then someone
like Wesley could capitalize yeah I
gonna disagree with both of you and I'm
gonna throw my hat in the ring and say
Hikaru Nakamura even though he just lost
I still think that he is a formidable
player and he'll be able to bounce back
and talking about bounce backs we do
have to look at round five matchups and
once again we have some treats in store
for all of you folks watching both on
presents and at home and there we can
see Fabiano Carolina will play Magnus
Carlson Anish giri faces off against
Hikaru and gukash plays alireza farouza
shakuria plays against Wesley so and
nordie Beck he does need to make a
comeback plays against Aryan tari so
what pairings catch your eyes
I have two games I have Mama jar of so
and of course Fabi Magnus okay yeah
Fabby Magnus for me I want to see
whether Magnus can continue his comeback
and also whether Fabiano can really push
on after beating Hikaru in the last
round yeah for me I think I want to see
how the Juniors get on Juniors I say
that lightly there were teenagers good
cash against borugia
oh it's very exciting
I forget that they're so young and now
they've been on the scene for ages these
teenagers they've been Grandmasters for
years despite still being in their teens
yeah I'm excited to see also how they do
in the classical I think that'll be the
real uh kind of that's what they're
focusing on those younger players the
blitz for them just gaining experience
but they are taking one at a time so now
it's the next game it's only six minutes
or seven minutes that they have to fight
it out and I think still they are really
enjoying playing but
don't you love to play Blitz I do I'm
I'm jealous of those guys I want to be
out there playing how about you Judah if
you had the opportunity would you be
sitting at the board right now well
sometimes it's tempting to to play some
Blitz Games even though I I did not
really play since I retired but it's
also fun to watch but probably in a few
years time maybe I will get back and
play some Blitz game so I saw you beat
Magnuson Blitz last year around the park
uh in Madrid and talking about Magnus we
definitely have to check out the
encounter that you guys have been raving
about Magnus Carlson against Fabiana
caruana and there you can see Magnus he
is a five-time Norway chess winner and
incidentally he's won four tournaments
in a row so if he wins Norway chess this
year he will have got a
I'm thinking of the word it's not a hat
trick episode only that's three it will
be an Olympic gold medal I don't know
and then he's also five-time fideo world
champion and reigning four-time world
rapid Champion as well as reigning Blitz
champion and well he has the highest
rating ever right 28.53 he's been higher
rated than that hasn't he was closing on
on 2900 and that's his goal he said
yeah he's uh he's maybe taken his eye
off classical chess in recent months but
yeah he still has a lot of uh goals left
to accomplish and I think the first goal
is to try and win this blitz tournament
despite the difficult start Magnus
Carlsen so yeah it'll be fascinating to
see how his form picks up after that
last game and it's interesting they've
won so many times this tournament
because many of the players strong
players have problems to play front of
Home crowd so it's also kind of tricky
right to play in front of Home crowd and
uh
well it's going to be interesting what
we're gonna see today just in the next
one hour and a half well it's
interesting you say that because
traditionally everyone when they talk
about Norway chess and Magnus they say
oh well he doesn't do very well in
Norwich ass and that's because his
results have been streaky because yes he
did win last year but he also had some
defeats in the Armageddon portion he
lost to Anand he lost to Ari antari uh
he also lost to Wesley as well but still
despite all this he bounced back and
managed to win the whole event and he
said I remember an interview I hope this
quietens the critics now
that I do do well in Norway Jazz what
more can you ask of me and there we see
Wesley so getting ready for his
encounter
yeah we're waiting uh chakra mamajorov
the leader of the blitz event so far to
sit down and start his game against
Wesley uh of course we have other
matchups that we will be following too
but Wesley looks calm I've got to say uh
if you talk about Blitz he's always one
of the favorites and now we see Anish
giri facing Hikaru can Hikaru recover
from the shock of losing on time in the
previous game uh Anish as well he's uh
he's definitely one who's improved in
Blitz and rapper chess over the last
couple of years
and I think the other big matchup
neither players are sitting at the table
but uh we'll come to that very shortly a
niche against Nakamura in front of us
and I think
I think players right how can they
recover in a blitz tournament for
example just within minutes they have to
recover and forgive themselves what they
have done I mean losing on time right as
the kind of the worst possible scenario
can happen to you especially if you're
such a player like Nakamura and and I
think this resilience is so important
for the players and they have it all
yeah they're I don't know how they do it
they're superhuman almost they are able
to shut down all emotions and focus on
the moves focus on the board forget the
past for me that's the most difficult
thing but we do indeed see Fabiano
caruana against Magnus Carlson for
different poses I think they're both
itching to get going and uh predictions
for this game
oh Magnus wins if I want him
if I want to give at least the chance of
it that he completes my my prediction
then he has to win this game actually
all the game yeah and Magnus has a huge
score actually against Fabi in Blitz
chess I remember in the speed chess
championship last year Magnus cruise to
Victory and uh won nearly all of their
games then okay it's only two moves in
three moves in but it's the English
opening and a very provocative start
from Magnus Carlton he's moved the black
Bishop a couple of times white Knights
have danced into the center of the board
still a well-known position of course
but with a reputation of being slightly
better for white and uh Fabi starting
with the English shows he really wants
to win as well
and there he goes you know he's chasing
Away the Dark Square Bishop who's
threatening to take the center
and one thing that I found very
interesting in in Fabiano's podcast he
kind of talked about how he rationalizes
his losses and these big moments and he
just kind of just says well you know
it's no big deal I've suffered worse
defeats in my career and I'm just going
to move forward and uh there you can see
the players just simply developing seems
very straightforward for both sides at
the minute yeah Judah it looks like a
reverse Sicilian looks like a sicilian
with colors kind of swapped here
who do you prefer I think a Magnus
should be happy for this opening because
it's going to be a very complicated game
with a lot of options plans
complications
and this is something what you want to
have right you don't want to play uh
Rye loppers or or Italian even it has
more life in this position that's what I
would think that he's going to bring
back his Bishop to D6 then he's going to
be developing 97 Knight f8 somehow it
seems to me that there is kind of an
easy play for black also
yeah there we go he does drop back his
Bishop preserving uh those pieces black
center I just
yeah I think it's been a huge success
for Magnus Carson right now but Fabi
advancing on the queen side B4 still yet
to be decided how black is going to
develop
and okay first putting pressure on those
Advanced White pawns yeah now why this
is asked do you want to play Bishop B2
you or no Rook B1 or you want to play B5
well he answered by pushing his Pawn I
mean what do we think about that because
it does give the opportunity for black
to lock down in the center as he's done
I I like it too I'm a big Santa person
and you give me Pawns in the center I'm
just completely ecstatic
yeah now big decision okay Magnus does
trade Knights leaving white with doubled
e-pawns and yeah
spawn black hair
locked it in protected past pawn and
that's going to be a thorn in white side
for the rest of the game you don't even
necessarily want to capture this Pawn in
the center because it will just be
replaced by a fellow port and black will
gain control of some uh some more
squares and white tonight is going to
act as a blockader there we go on to D3
sitting uh on a nice pretty Square it's
still yet to be seen the Breakthrough
but Magnus goes fine
this is my kind of Chess it's not a joke
no it really is not I mean it's it's
actually really serious because you
can't capture the pawn on F5 because of
course it's like E5 E4 is coming let out
the lion of the cage
I'm never gonna doubt Judith's
predictions
success for Magnus Carlsen and okay here
you can choose takes D4 yeah there we go
he does and white
you want to be out there you want to be
there at the board don't you
I don't know but Knight F6 even
sometimes it's confusion whether you
want to take on e4 later or you want to
play F4 and G5 and G4 and just go for it
no the very solid age yeah because he
wants your knight F6 but doesn't want to
allow the possibility of Bishop G5
pinning that night it's it's nice this
is the Magnus at his best
yeah he's back in business
he's back in the flow again you can't
take this Pawn because black advances
Pawn to E4 with a fork one of the white
pieces one of the white minor pieces
will drop off but uh yeah what else do
you do with Fabi you could just move
your Rook into the center but that won't
change anything somehow you want to push
C5
that that's the only thing I would think
of with white if you go down you might
as well go down fighting right well I
mean I have another oh no no now it's
been taken away from me but I did think
that it was possible to go Bishop G5 oh
gee five
that scares the living Dale outside of
me
I I don't know how I'd handle that G5 G3
G3 uh
white can escape with the bishop step
on there
Magnus just develops hitting a pawn very
sensible stuff maybe he's going to
reroute his Bishop uh kind of fire F7
round to this way I'm not sure sometimes
the bishop on C8 stands better more
powerful than on E6 because blocking The
Rook
I mean it has its drawbacks at the same
time I completely understand that he
wants to have connection between the
works and development just to have
everything yeah Bishop F7 I like though
with Bishop G6 idea and Fabi now moving
to under a minute
which does of course play a factor in
your psychological State yeah I think it
was just those huge blows of throwing
all the pawns forward for black Fabby
it's hard to react when your opponent
does that your opponent is just kind of
going for you going for you and it takes
30 seconds just to kind of uh figure out
what to do let alone actually kind of
calculate and here we go Fabi playing a
move like A4 non-committal useful of
course but it cost him a lot of time 30
seconds now for him and Magnus just
continues bringing all his pieces C5
eventually C5 will happen but probably
black is forcing C5 so it takes
everything on e4 and Bishop D5 yeah
that's an E4 and you say thank you for
the lights guys actually you might see
it happen right now because the players
are following that line you mentioned
dude it
Bishop D5 and E4 oh yeah
this is the kind of position you want to
get away run away with white pieces
you want to do you don't want these
challenges you kind of want to go let's
take back
this didn't work out those pawns are
rolling oh Queenie one not the go Queen
G4 at least to have one active piece
yeah oh well uh Magnus doesn't care
about the A5 Pawn instead he's just
motoring forward with his Pawns
he could take on C5
no he just wants to smash he wants to
check mate the pawns are rolling is is
E3 something to think about or you could
you go whether it works or not it's just
two times yeah yeah or just play E3 and
then they're Bishop C5 exactly yeah this
point also there's a lot of Temptation
and I mean F5 is very powerful also
well there we can see it Bishop D2 given
a question mark and Magnus centralizing
the queen coming out of harmful way yeah
really instructive he's not calculating
he's saving his time for later Magnus
probably had a direct win he could have
thrown pawns forward but why burn time
why take big risks there he's won the
pawn back level material and look at his
Center and look at fabi's clock time you
know just making moves with seconds left
on the clock and Magnus has an
overwhelming position and are we going
to see another trade of Works no
E3 we're gonna see yes in a second I'm
waiting for it well not yet maybe maybe
bishop C5 back here he comes
and that white king is being shown of
its uh protection here going through
that you've spotted something no I
thought that I I wouldn't like to leave
the bishop on A7 so white can play B6
that's the only thing uh war is isn't is
an E2 yeah
oh wow some tactics some huge tactics
against the white king the white Knights
acting as a blockader trying to plug
that diagonal but okay at least fabby's
found a way to lock out Black's bishop
and trade some pieces I wouldn't be
happy if it's black when uh White Bishop
on e4 simply black has too much of an
advantage maybe even G5 and Bishop D5
yeah I think we're gonna see that happen
right now and uh we see why tonight has
left the board and both players seconds
left for Fabi no time oh he's lost on
time but I'm afraid that was not the
only problem
oh
lost position for Fabi at the end he was
about to get checkmated on the light
squares but yeah too slow the clock
deciding this game as well and uh still
some action going in the other ones as
we do see and uh firstly Magnus Carlsen
the streak continues let's jump into
another game Anish giri against Hikaru
Nakamura it's a rook end game looks
roughly level but the clock might also
have a role to play in this one Judith
well it seems like pretty drawish I
would be very surprised if this will
have a decisive result
because
maybe there was something wrong because
maybe Oro had a better position because
he's shaking his head
and he's not happy with the draw but it
is
and there you go handshake for a second
though I thought Hikaru might forget
himself and lose on time but you know he
didn't did he no no no
because on the clock I see zero zero
zero but probably it was just they did
not say they didn't stop the clock yeah
yep the kings are in the center of the
board so that one was a draw and only
one game remaining in this round it's
gukesh against varusia a battle of the
teenagers we've been talking about the
young players and white has a knight in
that game but black has all the pawns
this is a funny end game but it should
be a draw because the H6 Pawn is far far
away and the white king is stopping the
other past Pawn so there is no other
outcome unless unless white is losing on
time because even if black losing on
time no mating
peace on the board so Knights are
notoriously bad though at stopping these
H pawns stopping these Rooks husband the
pawn is running he's just not stopped it
he didn't bring his stroke his Knight
nope
and uh Ali Reza farisa taking home the
point
yeah I I wasn't so sure about that night
in game I mean what do you mean the
night the pawn was on H6 only there must
have been a way to draw but he just
forgot to bring his Knight back there
was no time for the white king to run
oops that type of thing can happen with
only a few seconds on the clock
he fought so well but in the end
farrugia taking the point
and wow another bloodthirsty around so
many more decisive games and often
decided by the player uh with more time
being on the attack
wow just uh breathless action here
Ivanka absolutely it's been lots of
intense moments and we do have to take a
recap of round five scores and there we
see at the top of the table Fabiano
Carona losing with the white pieces to
Magnus Carlton it was a draw between
Anish giri and Hikaru Nakamura whereas
the cash we just saw tumbled against
alireza faroogia and it also a draw
between shakuria and Wesley and it was a
very important point for 18 year old
nordebec Abdus tarov who defeated Aryan
tari who still is trailing you know he
only has won one game
and this is lining up very nicely
because we now pass the halfway mark
for games remaining
four games remaining and uh let's check
out some of the action from that
previous round and uh it was here where
uh I've do some tour of with the white
pieces was able to Outfox ariantario of
Norway after Pawn takes Rook here it
looks like White's Pawn is about to
promote but it can be snapped off the
board and after Bishop takes Pawn white
was able to jump in with those tricky
Knights winning a Pawn on the F6 square
and after this Pawn dropped I think uh
that signaled the end of the game the
other Pawn later went on to fall and
Abdul sotorov with his Knights dancing
around was able to take the full point
small margins fine margins at this top
level but very quick and very tricky to
see this type of idea with no time on
the clock Abdul sotorov really showing
his class in the same game
this trademark right he's a universal
player but he's also fantastic at end
games and poor Arie antari you know he
is the underdog here and he will
definitely be struggling
in the main well that sounds bad I've
heard of it is not bad but you know well
he's the low lowest rate exactly that's
why obviously everybody wants to hunt
down right and of course it's very
difficult if let's say he's losing one
game then he can lose his
self-confidence he doesn't have such a
huge experience on this level yeah and
uh talking about uh the standings let's
take a look at the top is still Shakura
mamajarov with a very impressive four
points out of five and in during the
second we have alireza and Wesley so
both on three and a half points out of
five Magnus Carlsen with his two win
streak has now inched up to fourth place
and there at the bottom nine and ten
have a good cash and Ariane both on
1.05. not a very nice birthday day for a
good cash especially the last game was
also quite annoying but after all the
are the ones who are going to say okay
it's just a blitz please don't yes but
they're gonna play with five blacks well
there is a very good chance for that but
okay they are very young so yeah okay
well still four rounds remaining still
they can claw back some points
Anything Can Happen yeah it's not how
you start is how you finish was uh one
of my friends mantras when it comes to
chess and let's take a look at the round
six matchups
and once again I keep saying this but we
have the world's best players playing
here in Norway so that means we are
going to be treated to some fabulous
matchups and there we have at the top
Hikaru Nakamura against Magnus Carlsen
and then we see Ari antari against
Fabiana caruana Wesley so second place
against nordeback whereas alireza
farouza will be playing against the
tournament leader Shakura mamajarov and
Anish giri will play a good cash who
seems to be struggling on his 17th
birthday
and I think there's only one game that
we're going to be following in this
round and that's between Hikaru Nakamura
and Magnus Carlsen where else but it
could also be decisive for the standings
well actually if you were very close to
see a world championship match of that
new players right
and I think it's a it's one of the most
interesting matchup right here because
of course Nakamura is not a player who
is afraid of Magnus and they they have
some special uh uh environment when they
are just between them right across the
board so I'm really waiting something uh
special in that game and Magnus is black
again yeah and in recent times Hikaru
has maybe had the upper hand he beat
Magnus loss uh yeah on the speed Chess
Championship his results online have
been very good against Magnus in a bunch
of title Tuesdays recently feels like
Magnus he's let Hikaru get in his head
and for years it was the other way
around so that one is going to be
fascinating to watch yeah definitely and
we have to remember that Hikaru is
actually number two when it comes to
Blitz ratings you know he's there
pushing alireza faruja so it's not gonna
be an easy matchup at all for either
side
um who do you think if I'm gonna pit you
on the spot who do you think will be the
one to Edge it out okay and here we can
see some stats for Hikaru his five-time
U.S chess champion reigning five times
speed chess champion also I forgot the
stat but again it's there he's the
reigning world of fitter random World
chess champion and as well as being PCL
Champion with Gotham Knights and he's
also American Cup winner as well you
know he's won so many things in 2022 and
2023 after he was saying that he's kind
of a non-professional anymore right
I know yeah let's let's also discuss
that you know he says that he's a
streamer he he spends a lot of time
streaming after this I'm sure he will be
making a video and producing content
discussing maybe how can you do that and
still play world-class chess I think
that sorry I think the only thing it can
help that you put your your nerves of
all this pressure what you have because
of course there are a lot at stake when
you're playing tournament and you put a
lot of pressure on yourself you make a
lot of preparation you take everything
so seriously and since he went on
streaming he experienced the something
else that he gains a lot of
self-confidence he's successful
somewhere else also as much as in the in
the world of jazz and somehow it
balances out I think pretty well for him
that okay he does that when he goes to
tournament he's he's playing with less
pressure on his shoulder it's just a way
to relax himself interesting because
we've seen David and I have seen him
play like a main tournament and then was
those games while he was waiting for the
games to begin he would play another
tournament in between rounds and then
he'd go back and uh go on stream for
hours at a time uh he the man has
endless stamina Hikaru and I think
despite not thinking of himself as a
professional he's still spending more
time than ever on chess he's still
studying chess playing chess and
especially when it comes to Blitz he's
playing hours and hours every day so um
yeah I think that can only help him in
an event like this one with classical
chess I think that's the real Marvel the
fact that he can still perform so well
there but clearly he still works on
openings he's got a great second Chris
Littlejohn who helps support him there
and yeah he's uh yeah of course he's
naturally talented as well and that
really uh does help a lot and I think
the players are getting ready now in the
auditorium they're about to start their
games here we see Wesley so still doing
uh decently in the tournament against
Abdul satorov
and uh yeah we're itching we're getting
ready for that Marquee match up Hikaru
against Magnus
and uh yep the player's just waiting for
the Arbiters to tell them that they
could start the game Judith and uh
Wesley looking around
what's what's bothering him or just
impatient to get going and maybe he's
looking at the clock times and there we
see Fabiano with the black pieces facing
off against Underdog and the lowest
rated tournament a player of the
tournament ariantari
Fabiano will be looking to win this one
and here comes one of our players Hikari
Nakamura with the white pieces will we
see him switch up his opening
yeah he's been playing very solid stuff
but not the most exciting stuff in the
first few games with white and that
backfired against uh Carolina Judith but
maybe maybe he will follow up the same
thing and he wants to provoke Magnus
that okay I know you want to win I know
you want to win the tournament I know
that you want to kill me so show me
very solid play at the same time maybe
he's just going to be switching and it's
interesting that it's only a Blitz game
it's only a blitz tournament but for
sure when they sit down there and they
play out this five six seven minutes he
want to kill each other
just in case yeah and both of them will
have one eye on the standings as well
they know that Mama jorov has stormed
ahead into the lead and they'll be
wanting to catch up meanwhile wow Magnus
isn't at the board and the clocks have
started Hikaru playing his first move
Magnus uh a bit of a Gambit already and
it's not even move one
you can see that Nakamura is kind of
shocked that uh it did not show up at
this time and so as Magnus you know he
seems to indicate but he's not in a rush
look at that but this is this is
magnus's power move right we've seen him
do that before you know he when he
arrived two and a half minutes late for
that game in the blitz you know he
literally adjusted all his pieces before
he made his move I mean what kind of
power move is that
wow and uh the game has started after
Magnus kind of gives Hikaru 30 seconds
lead on the clock and it's the exact
same opening tunic that we've seen from
Hikaru surprised not surprised hit this
way he's not losing and wasting energy
rethink what to do yeah let's go for it
this is what I decided I want to put my
energy and they invested in other things
in the middle game and game
when you have to shuffle things the way
to to turn things around wow and Magnus
taking a long think it's only move six
this is really surprising kind of
forfeiting a few minutes on the clock
here pretty much and okay he plays
Bishop to F5 for a logical move
developing pieces and what does Hikaru
have in store just Rock Solid almost a
London system set up here for White and
the players will now just slowly develop
the pieces the action will be much later
in the game Magnus will hope that the
clock times balance out before that yeah
and uh Hikaru actually asking Magnus a
question now with this last queen move
he's just saying how are you going to
defend the pawn on B7 and still there
are some questions there because if the
queen does step forward I mean first of
all if I were playing with the white
pieces I would come in with my Bishop to
the B5 square and get ready to jump in
with the Knight on E5
yeah it looks very tempting now the
question is whether Bishop B5 can be
played with an idea of Knight E5 and
what Magnus has in mind whether is he
really going to play F6 to stop that
well just to cover the E5 Square hits
possible Magnus has done crazier stuff
but maybe he just wants to go Bishop D6
after Bishop B5
yeah well let's see yeah we'll find out
the answer to the question okay he
trades not now
is it too crazy to actually take that
night with the king
king will be stranded in the center of
the board for the rest of the game
that's true while he plays it Hikaru
really desperate to win here and Magnus
reacts lightning fast with F6 no night
jumps for you and wow I'm not sure it
was a good sign that it went this
direction no it was a bit one mind I
think he needed to because where are you
going with your king usually you're not
castling alongside in these systems
right right and and you and one other
thing that is quite concerning for white
is actually this light Square Bishop
that black has on the F5 Square because
the king is never going to find any
safety on the queen side with that piece
looming on the board
I mean black can even go very aggressive
G5 G4 kind of stuff
step forward
[Music]
but he Cara really Breaking All the
Rules because you know we're taught
first of all don't move your king into
the opening into the center and then
certainly don't open any lines he is
Fisher random world champion though and
this does look like a fish at random
game with the King out on D2 so will he
get time after the queen trade that's
about to happen to run back with his
King to safety I'm really surprised I
must admit by magnus's last move very
strange go for checkmate when your
opponent's king is in the center that's
what we're taught but I think he's just
saying simply saying look the bishop on
G3 locked out of the game that's true
and let's continue the dancing on the
queen side it's a good G5
H5 yeah
stepping forward with all the pawns he's
going to gain gain space on both sides
on both flanks here as black it's still
a beautiful position here for Magnus but
I'm really shocked he didn't go for
checkmate to try and punish well maybe
he just wants to play for one result two
results sorry
things that okay probably Nakamura so
will not feel too comfortable with this
with white because he just sits and wait
what kind of plans Magnus will work out
H4 G5 King G6 Rook d8
oops Yeah already this what's this D5 is
hanging yeah maybe just playing too slow
it feels like he's not quite in the zone
in this game instead of going for
checkmate he's been forced to allow a
bunch of Trades don't forget that Bishop
on H2 yeah one bad piece that's White's
problem long term right has nine pounds
maybe nine pawns and uh not enough
pieces
yeah okay but at least some pressure has
been relieved with this uh last exchange
this wants to be very instructive
C5 C4 sorry in every game and every game
somewhere a place it seems to be like
the formula right gets develop pieces
get C4 in ta-da you add some tactics
some tricks here you have to be really
careful it's black actually this pawns
being undermined and your knight is
really loose in the center of the board
yeah now
anyone's game I mean is White's idea so
if black were to double Rooks on the C
line it's just simply to go B4 Pro or a
problem for white for black that Rook C8
does not work because C takes D5 Rook C1
X on E6 and captures the Knight on
on e4 and okay the H2 Bishop is bad but
two Bishop versus The Rook is plus yeah
yeah huge threats how does Magnus deal
with this Pawn 6 Pawn is a winning idea
if he gets time Hikaru Nakamura suddenly
the clocks as well Magnus down to 30
seconds he's going to regret kind of
forfeiting that 30 seconds he played too
fast made decisions
oh wow what action it is all happening
fire on the board lots of calculation to
be done
and right now white can go upon up in
the end game if they just uh if Hikaru
here just takes this black Bishop with
the check and then recaptures on F3 but
he's thinking of something else but does
if he were to grab that pawn
his Bishop on H2 would be saddled there
until the end of times
and that's something that is
strategically rarely really concerning
very interesting this move with Magnus
played G4
he's not scared of getting his Knight
trapped on the edge of the board I would
be slightly uh kind of worried here if I
were Magnus Carlson this Black Knight
has no Escape squares that's why Hikaru
has stepped forward F4 taking away the
G5 Square from black snipe now all
Hikaru needs is to teleport his King
over to G2 wow no way back now for that
piece
Magnus playing with fire
King F1 Retreat Rogue G8 took C7
and White's playing with an extra piece
essentially the white king the white
Bishop they're kind of canceling out the
black Rook at night right now Magnus is
totally stuck totally immobilized
I hate what Magnus has been doing and
there we go Judith White's Rook is
activating
could we see white just be winning in
the next few moves
it's quite a funny setup having the
bishop on H2 Knight on H3 don't try it
at home that's uh the problem actually
the bishop is coming into the game
but uh Magnus is wriggling hard you know
mother Rick has come to G4 H4 is
threatened on the board the xh4 yes
takes and then you go H4 you win back
the piece you win back the white Bishop
at the end but I don't understand why
hikaru's there we go not just activating
his Rook you can hit my Bishop but I'll
just happily Retreat and the Black
Knight still trapped for the rest of the
game
that's under 20 seconds and his position
is concerning
positions more than concerning it might
just be lost here and under 10 seconds
as you say Ivanka
what next where's he going with that
black king really mysterious stuff he
can barely move and now Nakamura is just
going Pawn hunting going for black
spawns on the queen side and grab them
why not well
how many seconds 15 seconds for Hikaru
and he's taking some time out just to
see whether he can grab the pawn and
that's a good King G4
but now what Knight F2 King H3 he has
his magic ideas this is the definition
of magic Judith look at what he's done
the black king has crept into the
position he's going for the wind Magnus
if he can get his King into the F3
Square Hikaru has to pull the brakes and
he has to do it now
he's a piece up Hikaru but uh White's
Bishop is so trapped and the clock is
ticking down and the King has come to F3
wow what a resource by Magnus well the
pawns are disappearing still some
Checkmate threats Black's e-pawn
threatening to come forward and look at
the clock both players seconds left
indecision there from Magnus F4
he's just not taking a free Pawn that
feels like
now
Magnus has got to draw up his sleeve if
he wants it it feels like he can bring
his King across his car is just
repeating now bringing his Rook trying
to give a check hey Magnus takes the
pawn black has to be the favorite hatred
well the those two extra pawns F4 F3 and
nothing will stop him F3
keep pushing
now go three three times around still
he's just repeating moves here get any
time on the clock the players do have a
two second increment
but he's stuck how can he break through
here Magnus Carlsen King F3 and it's
gone
[Music]
E2 and rugby one
Judah I think you spotted a direct win
there he's still going to find it though
Magnus Carson he's got three pawns now
to be Pawn running
Hikaru is about to resign three pawns is
too much he's relaxed
what kind of h39 he had
and I mean oh my God what a game what a
turnaround I mean this just goes to show
it's all about holding the nerves when
the clock is ticking down on its final
seconds and here comes F3 oof what's
that isn't F what's that f f at this
point
and pawns are rolling black is about to
win
what a painful loss for Nakamura this is
not the way Magnus wanted to win
no but there's such a genius plan giving
up his night and just entering with the
black king just so resourceful to see
that idea that plan from moves ahead
with no time on his clock Magnus
deserving it in the end but yeah earlier
play questionable to say the least well
it was basically after the opening it
was like full huge Advantage right
and there you can see the big smile on
magnus's face because he knows he got
away with it but I have to say I mean it
was incredibly well fought by Magnus I
mean he had at some point quite a
terrible position but he found a way how
to mix things up and confuse Hikaru and
we do have to take a look at the round
six scores and there we see Magnus
Carlson winning an important point and
it was also an important point for
Fabiana Corona as he beat ariantari and
Wesley so lost to Nordic Abdul sotorov
and alireza farouza he won against
Shakura mamajarov so Sakura stepping
down the rankings and it was an
important win for gukesh on his birthday
as he now moves on to two points
or Fighting Chess I mean Norway chess it
is the Wimbledon of chairs of home to
Fighting Chess and the players they are
proving it here in the opening Blitz I
know it's just seatings and colors up
for grabs but boy the players are really
giving it their everything
and shall we take a look at the
standings
let's do it
and at the top of the table there's been
some movement because alireza farooja is
now on four and a half points out of six
he is half a point ahead of Shakura
mamajarov and look who's moved up the
rankings Magnus Carlson he's now on
three and a half out of six alongside
Wesley so and nordebec abdusa taraf and
at the bottom
poor old orientari who seems to be
having a tough day
oh
and uh well I think we've seen a lot of
hair-raising moments a lot of intense
challenges and we are going to take a
breather as we take a break and going
into around seven
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh yeah do you want to be black
yes okay
we have a no boys loud chess club
because it feels like in chess sometimes
there's too many boys who are just
you know critical or judgmental it's a
pretty intimidating space where it can
be when you go to a chess club and
there's no other girls there so we want
this to be a place where girls feel
comfortable playing chess it doesn't
matter if you're good or a beginner
that's what the chess cave is for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello and we are back and it's time to
reignite that chess fire as now there's
now been a change at the top it is
varuja who has toppled Shakira mamajarov
and let's dive in to the round seven
match-ups it is Magnus Carlson against
Aryan tari gukash takes on Hikaru
Nakamura Shakura mamador Anish giri and
Nordic abdusatorov against tournament
leader alireza farouza he's also
incidentally the number one rated Blitz
player in the world and then we finally
have the All-American matchup between
Fabiano caruana and Wesley so oh there's
some exciting exciting games ahead which
ones are your favorites
for me I think I want to see gokash
Nakamura also what's going on and of
course the youngsters yes no they're
back in delicious
and the players are off and we can see
it looks like it's a queen's Pawn
opening
uh it looks like the Spanish Spanish yup
the Roy Lopez it's an early stage in
this game the players have just started
but a quick start between these two
teenagers and not so theoretical here
Abdul sotorov with white has chosen a
slower approach dot Square Bishops are
off but everything else still on very
tense and Judith you had some experience
with these types of openings in your
career not really earlier I was never a
big fan of exchanging the bishop on E3
to to be honest I I like to have my
Bishop in G5 or to play Bishop D2 and
somehow bring my classical idea for
tonight E2 G3 F5 or something like that
at the same time I I like it kind of
having the bishop on B3 having The Rook
on the file so it can give some nice
powerful Initiative for white I think
Queen E1 is very typical going Queen H4
or queen G3 later on bring the double
The Rook on the F5 bringing out the
Knight to H4 F5 so that powerful Bishop
on B3 can be eliminated at the same time
with the plan of Bishop C8 Bishop E6
yeah and I think we're quite likely to
see that there's a lot of pressure on
Black's position so you want to
neutralize that by trading off pieces
but first you'll plan that Judith Knight
H4 coming into F5 I would be terrified
here I've got to admit if I were for
Russia but experience does show and uh
engines do show that black does have
nothing to worry about if if you're
defending carefully here so interesting
start to this game Bishop E6 indeed on
the board I think if those Bishops
disappear then black is far closer to
equality far closer to safety the
question is whether can white go Bishop
D5 or Knight D5 I think that's that's a
big question
yeah I think my D5 probably Bishop D5
right
and it takes the 597 and what the B3
Bishop will be doing
yeah and I think we're going to see that
variation you just mentioned on the
board and uh yeah change important
structures
[Applause]
oh you know it's a nice positional
sacrifice
after all you do get control over the
light squares and you do weak in Black's
King and uh well you see Ali Reza saying
doesn't bother me I'm just simply going
to return some material and simplify the
position yeah he's saying take my Pawn
please take my Pawn because the White
Knight is active the Black Knight
passive and that trade would only help
black who is material up so now we'll
see the blacking slide into the corner
there we go the black Rook will slide
over to the G file where it will plug
any holes and no attack it's all about
that white Bishop you talked about it
earlier dude it was the pride and joy of
White's position now it's just a dead
block of wood well it will come back
into play with C3 and Bishop C2
eventually especially after having the
queen on F5 but I'm afraid the F6 and
queen C8 will be the next moves of black
or yeah Queen E7 Rook G8
so it's white is kind of trying to look
for compensation which I'm not sure at
all that he has enough
I mean is I mean is it so bad for white
because white can reactivate the bishop
perhaps putting it to D1 and maybe to G4
and let it sit pretty on E6
yeah that's a really nice maneuver
actually and I think in action
prediction game on point Rebecca gotta
say and yeah I underestimated this
maneuver I thought the bishop would take
three or four moves to get back instead
it's kind of right back in the action
now and black is struggling to untangle
uh without dropping further pawns right
now white is up I'm sorry white is down
material is the exchange for a pawn but
still the black rook's struggling to get
in the game black probably wants to
exchange after all the Queens playing
Queen G6 in the next move at the same
time white is very much on time so he
doesn't have to exchange the Queens he
can move with the queen and the F5
square is controlled three times so
black cannot push F5
so this way
it's not so easy for black either so I I
think white will have enough
compensation after
when goes back Bishop F5 yeah it's
essential to keep the Queens on the
board right because with the Queen's off
the black rocks will gain in power later
on black will be able to open up some
lines and there we go nice move if Queen
takes porn I think black's Queen will be
caught on a bad circuit the white Bishop
will plant itself on F5 and there's
going to be a mating attack uh you
cannot get greedy there so black side
steps still this one in the balance I
mean look at that just few moves ago the
bishop was standing on B3 and we were
kind of complaining and suddenly magic
happened 96 the best location for the
person I officially eat my words I said
that Bishop was a dead block of wood now
it's the best piece in the position by a
mile beautiful play by a beautiful
maneuver from Abdul sotorov but there is
a problem with that Bishop yeah it's
sitting lovely on that square but you
know the black Crooks will simply travel
on the dark squares you know lift
themselves up you know E7 maybe even G7
and in the meantime there's not that
much white can do but there's not much
black can do either true
maybe it's just one of those games where
everything is in balance until someone
tries to disturb the force our white
wants to place the Rook to F5 and
control the square F5 and H5 possibly
black will try to go to G7 what G5 but
not now
or maybe you can do it you can do it now
I thought the cream was going to get
trapped but no well now it's important
for black that if the white Rook moves
then F5 is possible yeah
yeah and there was a big threat to take
White's Bishop the only defend of the
white Rook so White's pieces all have to
uh be very careful we're protecting each
other and here we go far Asia is trying
to do something and that is open lines
up for his Rooks on the other side of
the board on the queen side if he gets
an open line or two then long term his
Rooks might later be able to enter and
uh look how the evaluation bar didn't
really like uh Abdul Sartorius reaction
there opening up two files but it makes
a lot of sense the white pieces look
nice and pretty on the light squares
black has some loose Pawns how to react
here and he's trying to get in well
that's a very logical reaction for black
to enter and enter to the second rank
bother a little bit the white king
how dangerous it does look scary but if
we're cold-blooded about it I mean can
you just go Pawn grabbing because that's
the first question I always ask myself
upon grabbing for white white yeah yeah
I think white would love to grab some
pawns but first black has to decide
whether to check
oh nerves of Steel to F3 marching
forward I would be too scared I'd
Retreat my rook and just hope for
survival well we're gonna see the Rick
Retreat and uh now well pawns have
disappeared from the board and now big
threat from whites actually capture The
Rook on f8 oh it's scary for black I
mean yeah change of uh are we just gonna
say a Perpetual check
yeah the problem is Black's Rook might
not be able to get in I don't think you
should go backwards you might have been
uh checkmated there by the black Rook
coming across and down but instead white
stepping forward with the King and again
if you continue checking the white king
will find safety uh it might find safety
on this side of the board so yeah but
black will have to go for the budget
check and then yeah that's it he does it
like a draw he doesn't have that much
time as well 14 seconds on the clock and
obviously this will have an impact on
his decision making but both players are
wildly ambitious in general they hate
those drawers so who's going to play on
for the win for Asia's the first to
start repeating will you see the
handshake
Moment of Truth for abduce the tour of
now and we do see the draw by repetition
wow good result for both and really well
played game actually yeah a real tussle
there and oh
and uh farouja he cements his lead at
the top and shall we have a look at
someone else yeah let's go to another
game and uh Magnus against ariantari and
it looks like there might be a big shock
on the cards here Magnus has been
storming back he's on a winning streak
after a difficult start and he might be
going down to his countrymen I think he
blundered some huge blunder happened
there isn't it
wow wasn't that the case well we have a
result Magnus Carlson did lose to our
antari
yeah until we will go back to delve into
what happened in that clash between the
two Norwegians here at norwichs but uh
first the game remaining is kukesh
against Hikaru Nakamura and this one is
a very tight end game it should be a
draw with the best play but anything can
happen at this time limit white has a
rook and Bishop black has a rook and
three pawns level material but the side
with the pawns must be the only one who
can win here surely Hikaru can he press
this one to Victory do you think shoot
it I don't know but for sure he's going
to be trying I think generally speaking
it should be a draw unless there is a
huge blunder but we've seen something a
huge blunder by go cash previously where
he had Knight versus three pawns and he
somehow failed to make a draw
but now I see that obviously he's he's
focusing very much and he doesn't want
to let it happen again something similar
yeah and uh well we can see Hikari is
shaking his head and he did let his
clock go down to seven seconds but uh
here comes the pawns but it does look
like kukash has a very comfortable
blockade on the dark squares
should mention some symmetry in the
previous clash between Hikaru Nakamura
and Magnus Carlson it was also Recon
three against rook and Bishop but this
one is very different now the pawns are
easily blockaded by White's bishop and
King and this is about to be a draw it
is just don't put the bishop on a bad
Square keep it in contact with the g2
pawn and there you see the players
interestingly finishing the game
finishing up and it is a draw between
gukash and Hikaru
and actually incidentally gukesh is one
of the few players that actually set up
the pieces before he leaves
yeah a lot of the players only set up
the pieces if they've won the game we
saw that from Magnus Carlson against
Hikaru Nakamura but uh either way
disappointing result for Nakamura who no
longer really can hope to challenge for
first place in the splits tournament and
it looks like Wesley so has an opinion
on this end game and is saying
maybe this is how Hikaru could have
perhaps pushed the point home
yeah it's lovely actually to see the
players analyzed like this to see them
kind of uh analyze and just discuss
purely the chess on its own and
yeah missed opportunity potentially for
gokesh in this one
the car is having none of it however and
wants to get out of there well he has to
get over it in a minute or two and start
the next round right it's around eight
coming up
yeah getting close to the end so this
was round seven and completely and we
should take a look at the round seven
scores and we saw Magnus Carlson losing
in a shocking manner to Ari antari and
it was a draw between gukash and Hikaru
whereas it was also a draw between
Shakira and Anish which means that
Shakura is still in second place and
nordie Beck Abdul satorov Drew against
alireza fuja meaning farrugia is still
half a point ahead of Sakura and also a
peaceful result between Fabiano caruana
and Wesley so
yeah and uh just to delve back into some
of the events of the previous round we
did see Magnus Carlton crashed to a
shock defeat to Countryman and uh
ariantari and it was in this position
Magnus had been losing some control he
had a winning position earlier in the
game but it was here that he finally
slipped he blundered simply a queen in
one move here for example the safest
would be Knight takes Bishop you also
have a variety of moves you could step
forward with B7 if you're feeling
ambitious but the one move not to play
was retreating the White Knight to the
center going for checkmate against the
black king but forgetting about blacks
attacking resources Bishop C4 check this
must have been a shock to Magnus
suddenly the white king is hit only one
safe Square for the king and this would
have ended in Checkmate just a huge
blunder and after Bishop C4 check he was
forced to part with his Queen but of
course he wasn't able to save this game
Queen takes bishop and Ariane went on to
convert very smoothly big result for the
standings definitely a big result for
the standings and let's take a look at
the set standings after seven rounds and
alireza faruga still at the top with
five points out of seven half a point
behind him is Shakura mamajarov and
everything to play for Wesley so half a
point behind Shaq with four points as is
nordebec Abdul satoroff and Magnus
Carlson well he lost an important game
there and he's now on three and a half
points out of seven alongside Fabiana
caruana and Judith are you shocked by
some of these results
well I think we can say that on Magnus
the way he lost I'm kind of shocked
because he everything went on the
direction that he can he can give a a
good uh game and possibly win also the
game but it's very interesting how
alireza is just slowly but surely he is
climbing up and actually he's there
number one right and I'm very curious
how mama jaro will be able to finish in
his last two games yeah it feels like
farusha with two rounds remaining must
be the huge favorite but as you say
Judith if manager gets back to the
winning ways gets back uh especially if
he strikes in this next game Nerfs could
be jangling I think that first place
getting the first uh kind of opportunity
to pick seeding for the classical
tournament that's what all the players
of course are hoping for but also in the
middle of the pack is the top five so
let's keep an eye on those games in the
middle as well picking seatings and uh
one thing to be aware of is that if you
do have first choice and you do pick
seed number one you will start off with
two whites and the person who's unlucky
to pick number six actually gets two
blacks in the first two games
yeah not the start you want the black is
tough at the best of times but
especially against these Giants and
potentially black in the Armageddon
games a huge disadvantage so everything
to play for in this next couple of
rounds and talking about a couple of
rounds let's take a look at the round
eight matchups and it's Wesley so last
year's winner of the blitz portion
against Magnus Carlson he's actually won
the overall Norway chess event four
times in a row and Hikaru Nakamura faces
off against orientare elyriza farouza
plays uh Fabiana Carana Anish giri plays
nordebec Abdul sotorov whereas 17 year
old gookash it's his birthday plays
Shakura mama jarov and Judith which one
is the biggest match for you I'm very
curious how gokash can continue his his
tournament and what is he going to show
against Muhammad yarov I think that's
one of the most interesting game for now
and you David yeah for me it's actually
the leader alireza farouza can he keep
it up if he wins his last two games he's
won it he's won the blitz tournament so
against Fabiano he'll be hoping that he
can strike now and do you think alireza
will manage to maintain his form because
normally the players when they reach a
certain point they start to Coast it
yeah Nerfs might kick in if you relax
too soon it could backfire I do however
believe in alireza his split skills are
just so good he's so fast and nerves
don't seem to affect him that much so I
think he's the big favorite at this
point yeah we have to remind ourselves
as well alireza is number one in the
blitz ratings at 2900.
just such a big rating
please they care they care about Blitz
ratings Magnus will be devastated by his
last game for example because he's
throwing Blitz rating points away so uh
yeah important for many reasons these
last few games
not just the standings at stake
oh what a tournament so far a lot a lot
of stressful moments for the players for
sure there will be a lot of things to
recover
how do they adapt back to classical
chess after this madness student
crazy stuff
and there'll be a lot of the
work for the sack
ER noting certain like habits that
players have
well I think they just have to get over
with it of course after the tournament
for half an hour maybe they will be
discussing these kind of things what has
happened what kind of blunder I did what
were the greater disappointing moments
at the same time they will just go for
dinner and think about tomorrow yeah
prepare and prepare their mindset for
the classical game right is this kind of
is it are the results of the blitz
portion that's something to reflect on
later
they care a lot about the Armageddon
part of the tournament that will be very
interesting and and that is something I
think very challenging for the players
to switch from classical game to to
Armageddon because it really counts
yeah it's one of the few tournaments
where when you have a draw it's all
decided by Armageddon and that's quite a
difficult mind shift as well and there
we can see alireza getting ready to face
off against Fabiano caruana stretching
and it's a good mood it is totally in a
good mood now interesting enough I mean
would you categorize alireza as a
professional player because he said you
know he wants to take a step back from
his chess playing because he wants to
focus on design
I would say he is still I mean until
we're given more details about his
career in fashion design it seems to be
what he still spends most of his time on
if not all and he's still competing at a
high level how can you not be a
professional player when you're taking
down the best players in the world on a
regular basis but uh either way yeah
it's his future and it's nice to see
farisha here supported by his whole
family it feels like all the ingredients
are here for him to have a successful
tournament we also see Wesley who's had
a consistent tournament a bit up and
down but he'll be hoping to end up in
the top five places of course in the
blitz to get that extra white in the
classical section Wesley Mr consistent
he's also Mr practical
I I've noticed you know when when you
provoke him he comes out like a bear
roaring but until that moment he's quite
happy to do what is needed and he's
happy to conserve his energy and there
he has the white pieces against Magnus
Carlson
well I think generally for the players
this Bliss tournament is about the
primarily to have white pieces in the
classical to gain this opportunity and
only secondary question is that how it
really works out at the final result
and we see Ali Raza there smiling
getting in good spirits as he faces off
against Fabiano caruana seems very
relaxed
yeah very relaxed and uh caruana
meanwhile the complete opposite looks
very focused and he will of course be
wanting to play the role of spoiler of
course also essential for him he's
around the middle of the pack Fabiano so
a win would get him closer to that uh
coveted top five spot so we are about to
have liftoff in this game we see the
handshake and quick move from farrugia
whoa am I seeing this right or one
before the Polish opening okay
the orangutan opening
wow this does not have a great
reputation Magnus Carlson lost with it
just last week maybe maybe that's why he
was smiling that somebody was telling
him play one before but I remember
Magnus doing this type of stuff as well
you know he did it against Anish giri
and they were like thinking oh what's he
gonna do E4 D4 and like no B4
we're like oh ho ho
yeah what do you think I'm skeptical I
don't know this is the type of thing
that can derail the tournament if you're
coasting if you're doing well keep with
the same strategy don't just throw in
random openings like this one and Fabian
is the type of guy who will be well
prepared and might well punish you white
does have an extra Central Pawn but
black has grabbed a B Pawn and look how
active Black's pieces are have has
anyone been brave enough to test this
against you in your career no actually I
think never in Blitz game yes yeah but
in classical nobody
the yeah that was a funny start
funny start and uh yeah I don't know
quite the kind of quite the explanation
behind this opening but I remember uh
Ivanka after you mentioned Magnus played
it uh last season on the Champions chess
tour I once went to a zoo because he
insisted on going to the orangutan
section just to take out photo uh
because he'd played the opening one week
before these top players they have
reasons for everything but there's
always a method behind the madness
and yeah I just saw a nice message from
a chat saying the evaluation bar already
angry doesn't approve I mean
I look at this position for white and I
think what is white doing because black
has the center
whites moved around with the dark Square
Bishop quite a few times I have to say
and
I I would just be thinking about pushing
that D Pawn one square forward and now
now it's in the air
yeah but white can maybe get ambitious
here and capture the Black Knight on F6
with his Bishop with his dark Square
Bishop I think you have to pretty much
do it otherwise black will step forward
as Ivanka mentions well maybe D4 is also
possible but then Knight D4 can be very
strong this is the challenging question
Bishop F6 grabbing the D5 Knight B4 Rook
C1
because Queen A1 was attacked ooh sneaky
threat though yeah and he will regain
his Pawn in the near future Fabi and
with a very nice position farouza here
just trying to do the question is he
going to take it back they should be
seven Queen B3
you're holding on for dear life I'm
trying to hang on with my phone on D5
but it's one of those things that
it reminds me of a situation like in
those iqp positions where you give up a
pawn and hold on to it but as soon as
black wins it back your White's position
just simply crumbles
yeah the question here is whether
farooja can give this Pawn back under
good circumstances in the right scenario
he can maybe equalize uh I would be
racing to get the white king to safety
but he goes for Judith's plan here just
defending this Pawn black will gang up
against it most likely now well Rook 88
is a very simple way of continuing yeah
it's what has been played yeah the
problem is you can step forward to
defend this Pawn but then you will get
hit along the e-file uh Rook to E8 and
there will be massive problems for white
so far Asia wow very ambitious play D4
he's hoping to strike maybe even regain
a pawn if the D5 straggler is captured
would have castled already it would be a
completely different story but there is
still a very important tempo which was
not done by white to put the king into
safety at the same time D4 I like very
much because I was wondering about this
move and I was like no it's Coffee House
chess you can't get away with it but
looks like you can fabby's throwing
another Pawn on the fire here you have
to take on B5 I think actually maybe
there are options there and white uh
Black's idea sorry is to take on D5 and
things get crazy but because white
hasn't castled tactics might work out in
Black's favor uh the alternative maybe
white can go D take C5 yeah C4 grabbing
the pawn bishop D5 is for compensation
for black
at the same time white has a nice bone
on C5 there
yeah and he spent a lot of time now for
Russia down both players down around the
115 mark on the clock he has to choose
you either take the put B5 Pawn with
your bishop or take C5 they're totally
different of course but they look
roughly uh kind of similar in terms of
evaluation and okay what are they
thinking about just take that Bishop
this is going to get Lively you need
your time for a bit later on no maybe A5
wow C6
so creative counter-attacking chess now
C6 is not good with xc4 and Bishop A6
yeah you have to take on B5 now if
you're far what's he thinking about is
he just gonna drop back his Bishop
White's Bishop is attacked no more
counter-attacking you have to react have
to retreat Maybe
this is crazy in this position it looks
so Random why does two pawns up but one
of them is about to drop yeah I did
wonder the whether you could counter
attack but no you're right not possible
spending a lot of time down to 35
seconds he has to take the spawn surely
or at least move his Bishop D5 will fall
maybe you go back this way maybe this is
the solid one just to defend your night
B5 must be the move but
any move at this point 20 seconds yeah
good nerves all right
okay he does drop the bishop to E2
but whereas if I was a shocking
E5 was a shocking well for a fellow
feroza yeah shocking in a good way hit
uh just totally throw off throw off
Rouge and this Pawn is dropping watch
out for these two black pawns to maybe
March down and decide things later I
mean can you not grab that pawn right
now yeah I would with the Knight yeah
yeah just grab it take it
maybe you can trade Queens first maybe
that's similar
wow even more ambitious Queen G6 ignored
there's some threats against this Pawn
but don't take it yet because white will
play Rook G1 and there's a
counter-attack against Castle
oh uh it's Black's move though first and
196. white just played Rook D1 last move
and it's given a question mark by the
computer there's I mean there's this
Pawn there's this check here on C2
hitting the white king there's so many
tempting moves yeah I mean I must admit
I'm just so greedy I will just capture
the pawn on A2 and then
push my pawns okay and I can see yeah
that's what happened but the evaluation
bosses
not the best decision
yep he grabs a poor now back and is that
white Queen trapped not quite she can
find safety on D2 Fabi it feels like
maybe just a bit too slow there if white
gets one more moving castles
verusia should be safe
he needs something now
and uh Fabi now down to 12 seconds and
big decision time and that's why he
steps forward with a bishop right can
can he grab on B2 G2 no because Rook G1
Queen B2 Queen B2 what a good place for
the queen
finally better late than never he's
castled on move 23 as white you normally
want to do that a bit sooner but still
chaos that black knight C3 is extremely
good
getting pieces off the board though so
if he can survive he's still a point two
winning material oh some back rank
tricks
[Music]
who black playing H6 just to give the
black king some breathing space
wow maybe you take only two and the
black queen is coming into D3 this one
looks like virus is blundered he's lost
control the black queen Zooms in
this one is going to be decided it looks
like there must be a checkmate
another pin Black's pieces all ganging
up and yeah there we go material is
dropping Fabby Ben E3
oh for four and it's all falling apart
for farugia
and he's uh just grabbing material now
cashing in
black is up the exchange Rook for Knight
and White's King's still not safe six
seconds versus four and now Brooke a one
threatened
but just look at the how farisha has
picked up the pace yeah that's what I
think spirit is there
uh fighting spirit I mean he showed that
by playing one before and uh he's about
to be punished Fabby has crept in
hesitation though counter-attack maybe
Black's Queen I don't know what he's
done with it on h24 no well it's coming
back in after H and now Queen will come
to F5 and now maybe The Rook will and
Roxy serve join the uh the fun
okay everything's defended now but other
than those pawns and fabby's cashing in
just stop gotta stop that white knight
jumping too much and the game should be
won
and here we go fabby's got control now
he's just gonna mop up nothing can stop
him
he could go also Rook C7 exchange
simplify
yeah good technique though he's just
kept everything covered and
well I thought he was going to grab some
pawns but still some work to be done
oh what is Fabi doing just I jinxed him
commentators the king can run to f8 so
it's okay
but did you see the live news speed of
Arusha as he
lost some knife Forks in the air you've
got to be really careful nobody Knight
F6 sorry
oh he pins the White Knight but this is
just delaying some pins Black's king
queen and Rook
all lined up
well anything could happen here you can
see three no just the phone okay no but
he's grabbed but this was not a good
decision to take that phone
is coordinated again look at the Knight
on e4 right
it's controlling everything
that's King's best friend
King goes all the way to G8 what a crazy
game White's King is gonna hide in the
enemy camp one it doesn't hide for long
that is Checkmate smiling
[Laughter]
he almost got away with it the Checkmate
absolutely and uh well Ali Reza he was a
tournament leader losing which means
that everything will now come down to
chakra mamajara for the he can score
something against kukash and I'm looking
and it looks like chakra one
yeah just as the moment you said that to
Ivanka Shakira did take the win and wow
takes the lead in the tournament again
yeah and uh there we can see the playing
Hall the players are ready The
Spectators are watching in Keen
anticipation and let's take out take a
look at the round eight scores we see it
was a draw between Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson and Hikaru did beat Ari antari
at Lee Reza farouza losing to Fabiana
Corona with the white pieces and someone
else who also lost Anish giri to Nordic
Abdul sotorov so that's an important
point for Nordic who now climbs up the
standings and could cash losing to
chakra which means that Shakira is now
tournament leader and one round left
this has been absolutely scintillating
stuff and uh shall we take a look oh
yeah let's take a look at some of the
action from the previous round of course
so many decisive games every round and
uh we want to bring as much action as
possible to you so it was this position
between Anish giri and Abdus that things
got really heated black has the bishop
pair black is a pawn up but giri here
spotted a tactic and went for it Bishop
takes G7 tricking luring the black king
forward and he was reliant on this
skewer hitting the black queen and the
bishop behind it but this trick Queen C3
was able to save the day for Abdul
sotorov keeping white Rook honest
keeping an eye on this rook in the
corner and I think over the next few
moves giri lost the plot he wasn't able
to find counter play and Knight to D4
wasn't the right direction here White's
Rook sliding going for the black king
but black was safe enough Bishop B7 a
really nice move reasserting control the
King was able to hide in the corner and
black had an extra piece simply uh
tactics that backfired for Anish giri
when it rains it pours anishagiri
suffering here and Norway chess opening
Blitz still everything to play for
because this is just a precursor to the
main event which will begin tomorrow and
let's take a look at the blitz standings
and you have to remember the players are
playing for who gets the pick of the
first seating so if someone chooses seed
number one then they start off with two
whites and they get five whites overall
and there we see in the lead Shakura
mamajarov with five and a half points
out of eight he's closely followed by
two players Ali Reza fuja and nordebec
abdusitorov both on Five Points Fabiana
caruana and Wesley so both on four and a
half points out of eight and Magnus four
points out of it I mean how surprised
are you to see Magnus Carlson there in
sixth place
I'm a bit surprised especially there he
was winning up three games and he was
very close to climb up to the top three
or even to the clinch the first place
but this is really not so important it's
not the life or death right and it's
interesting to see the top that another
back for example he's up there really on
the top and uh well of course still
Magnus is and Wesley slow I think they
are still fighting for getting an extra
white from tomorrow in the classical
tournament yeah this is such an
important round for not just Magnus who
wants to win to get that extra white but
also Hikaru Nakamura they are joined now
in sixth and seventh place if they win
they might get that extra white but they
really have to go all in in this final
round of the Blitz
and let's take a look at the final round
matchups and some big pairings in store
for us all as the players all jostle for
those important placings and we see
Magnus Carlson will be playing against
alireza farooza Shakira mamajarov plays
Hikaru Nakamura in order of gukash
whereas Fabiana Carona will face off
against Anish giri and for Aryan tari he
will meet Wesley so
oh so which which parents catch your
eyes uh for me absolutely the top two
magnus's game against firoza that will
be a hard game and of course the mama
jar of against Hikaru
yeah there's so much at stake uh Pride
tournament Victory those extra whites
it's all happening in those two top
clashes I think we'll be following those
two very closely absolutely and do you
think that Magnus and Hikaru who both
are in a must-win situation if they want
to finish high up in the standings
do you think they can do it
they can but they might be facing
opposition who will be happy to shut
down the game for example managero if he
knows he'll clinch at least joint first
uh with a draw in this final game and
also Hikaru starting with black is going
to be difficult for him against uh mama
jorov if namajorov isn't feeling up for
a fight that being said it's maradara
style to go all out so still some
chances maybe to counter-attack I would
be surprised if a major of goes for a
draw
yeah I think it's I mean
hi to go for a draw he he does not have
to force matters that it's it's really
have to be a decisive game but I think
definitely he will try his best yeah I I
did hear some complaints from Mama jar
of himself when you know he was told you
know you're getting older play play like
an old man you know shut the game down
and he said I can't do it but there's no
chance for me and I agree with you I
think we are going to see all action
there and uh this Pride at stake I think
it will hurt Magnus and hurt Hikaru to
be finishing in the bottom half of the
standings and playing with four blacks
as a especially that Nakamura started
extremely stable and very well in this
department so probably he's not going to
have a very good mood after the event
but okay
yeah
yeah and they they will want to end on a
high uh they will start their classical
games tomorrow but you don't want that
bitter taste in your mouth of losing
your last game in the blitz or having a
terrible run at the end of it it will
Dent your confidence and especially with
the Armageddon games in mind it's a
similar format similar kind of speed
needed so they will want to get in that
zone now and uh there we can see the
playing Hall as the players are gonna
enter
the whole for the very first very last
time today and who's that there's
ariantari he's pacing he's getting into
that pre-game ritual and uh there we see
this is that an Arbiter in the corner
yeah we have some Arbiters there we have
a lot of fans in the auditorium it's a
really nice venue here in Stavanger at
Norway chess and uh the players yeah one
last time one last time today one last
game it's been so fast I must admit so
Furious uh just non-stop action from
move one
Rises I I I I do think that this round
we're gonna see some moving and shaking
and some people playing the role of
spoilers just for fun and I have my eyes
on Magnus and Hikaru they say you can
finish at the top but I'm gonna bring
you down or not
wow is this a first Magnus Carlson to
arrive to be the first to arrive in the
playing Hall I've never ever seen that
I've got to admit maybe he thinks that
if he arrives first he can leave first
he wants to get over with even true I I
think Magnus you know he will want those
five whites oh and it turns out he was
just putting his jacket on the chair and
then he's gone again oh wow Keeps Us
guessing the elusive Magnus Carlson
and someone who is sitting at the board
is
currently in joint second and he will be
playing against yukash who has struggled
in this event on this day
yeah Norway chess is one of his first uh
huge kind of elite tournaments here at
go cash he hasn't had too much
experience playing these big round
Robins with the very top guys in the
world so
um it might just take him a few days to
find his feet he was here here I think
two years ago when he won the open
section and that's also partly he's
invited but of course he's a 2700 player
number 17 in the world so
yes and I can remember in tata steel he
played and that it was again a struggle
for him you know especially at the
beginning but then he found his feet as
all youngsters tend to do and he seemed
to have gotten better and better as the
event progressed and there we see Magnus
with the white pieces I just take his
piece I do you know what I've never not
seen a player not adjust their pieces
especially at the top level they're very
kind of uh they're very particular
detail it's a ritual
but I can tell it makes for very strange
viewing too someone who hasn't played
chess before
and well Magnus opening opening with the
B3 B3 Cowboy
let's rock and roll yeah and Magnus did
this at the world rapping and Blitz
championship and he had huge success
with one B3 scored almost entirely wins
there uh with this opening basically
just emerging with a non-theoretical
position very quiet line here it's
basically a reverse London system
whisper it quietly but those London
system fans will be very happy with the
way that farugia has developed as black
and early Pawn push aiming to punish B3
and okay the queen side completely
blocked up at this early stage they're
just freestyling now it's all about who
comes up with a better middle game plans
actually when they're playing with the
white pieces they're actually very
content to play
colors an opening that you'd normally
play as black and they're just saying
well you know I'm a Tempo up I don't I'm
just gonna say this is a small tiny
advantage and just get you into my
comfort zone as opposed to yours and
well Magnus making a typical Pawn break
in the center
and usually black does not want to
release the tension if farugia does
trade off a set of Pawns in the center
that only helps white first he posts up
his Knight on a very nice Square on B4
and Magnus does the same in the center
yeah and I don't need five it's also
very nice and probably he prepares F4
for later
getting ambitious it's really annoying
for white that your queen is tied down
defending the C2 Pawn you would love to
activate her a bit later on this Black
Knight is going to be a real Menace for
the rest of the game
this is why it was important for black
to play A5 forcing A4 this means that
there's a good Outpost for the Knight on
B4 and also white is not going to play
C4
first the white king is kicked into the
corner and alfarusia is lining up on d8
I've had some experience in this type of
position myself and I always favor Black
it's just easier to move
already maybe it he takes E4 is also
something to consider and open up the D5
yeah a rook staring down at the Queen's
always uncomfortable
I do feel it's gone wrong for Magnus I
mean and I would kind of point to that
a2a4 move way back because my experience
in those type of positions is that white
tends to handle A5 by playing A3 so you
don't have these pesky pieces sitting
there on the B4 Outpost
and meanwhile Magnus is contorting
himself rookie too uh I guess indirectly
in some variations he might be
protecting this vulnerable C2 Pawn but
either way mysterious stuff and now if
this Central tension is released Magnus
will most likely capture back with
pieces it's very tense it's kind of a
prophylactical move I believe that it's
uh protecting the D2 Knight is
protecting the weakness on F2
potentially protecting the C2 Pawn if
one stick Knight will be able to move
away
and also opens up the road for the queen
later on to move the way to F1 G1 or
something like that
yeah at first it feels like a waiting
game for Asia putting his Queen on A6 a
bit of a bizarre square but maybe some
tactics along this diagonal a bit later
on this might be the slowest uh two or
three moves I've seen in a Blitz game
ever both players really struggling to
come up with anything and Magnus is the
first to Flinch the first to Blink here
and uh he releases the tension for the
first time in the game a pawn trade has
happened and okay he's coming around
with his Knights I like this I like it
too because I didn't like the text E4
option for black maybe I would even
suggest that it would be an interesting
try immediately
because now Knight on E5 and potentially
there's another place for the other
night on D4 B2 Bishop is very powerful
white has the dream uh kind of fan
shattered Bishops watch out for things
opening up later they'll favor those
pieces
but still very much in the balance I
guess Black's idea is to try and
challenge this Knight
maybe he's going to drop back this night
but either way white has two glorious
pieces in the center and Magnus going
forward against prophylactical move
against Knight F5 he wants to stabilize
his Knight on D4 look at that Knight B5
is not possible Knight F5 is not
possible
whoa he's going forward immediately
Magnus Carson I thought he would try to
set up his uh Queen and Rook first
before opening the position but he's
really storming forward and he's
utilizing the fact that this bishop
might be undefended in certain
variations if black does open things up
the question is why is it so problematic
for black and black captured upon
I would take it and just close my eyes
and pray for the best here because if
you don't take this pawn it looks like
you're getting uh flattened getting
steamrolled
well it's under attack for starters and
how do you defend it
you have to take the pawn on F5
what is Magnus got up his sleeve there
is he maybe gonna push this pawn and win
this one later on it looks a bit clumsy
for white though maybe he wants to take
back on a five and after Knight F5
Bishop H3
oh wow so Pawn takes and uh later lining
up the bishop with some tricks on this
diagonal having The Rook on G2 Queen on
G1 and put extreme pressure on the G5
he's gonna swing it across here are
there also any tricks after Pawn takes
Pawn to actually jump forward with the
Knights to D7 and
look in that direction at the weak
Bishop yeah I think the Rook can move to
E8 and defend the bishop he's got to
move for Russia he's down to 20 seconds
we've just been playing too slow the
last few moves and wow a really creative
way to try and defend this Pawn maybe
indirectly some Knight F7 in the air
sorry yeah I can feel your Spidey senses
your Tactical sense is tingling here
dude at some tricks Association is huge
yeah first just take this Pawn I don't
really see what Black's got in mind
black structure is not great there
anyway
maybe also just bring the queen across
just protect this one
yeah after Queen F1 maybe e takes F5 and
Bishop F6
E1
I'm thinking is huge for several
different moves
wow such a slow pace only we moved 20
and both players now really low on the
clock Magnus just over 30 seconds he
needs to decide I would just take this
pawn and then start to figure out what
to do with my pieces but Magnus First
kicks back the Black Knight
it feels like this helps black though
and well now he's going for that trade
and is he going to capture now that's
the question is going to take ec6
D3 singing that's the problem right and
suddenly the queen on A6 which was
locked out of the game
is back in there what nerves wow in
seconds and now with Magnus less than 10
seconds on the clock and the position is
wild and uh he is in fact going for
those trades and does grab the E6 Pawn
and while Magnus he has profited from
this uh from this little transition here
supporting up and he's blocked out the
black queen
you think it's it that's it Judith no
way to fight back well Queen on A6
Bishop on H7
Rook H6 will show up
he's getting his Queen back into the
game for Russia here he's gonna try and
fight white still needs The Knockout
blow upon up but that's not the end of
the game yet
Magnus though in charge anyone if
there's one thing we've seen we've seen
that faruget can play at lightning fast
pace and there we see a trade of works
and oh Agnes has given up his Queen but
he's cashed in and he's broken through
the black defenses he's got a rook and a
piece for the queen but he's about to
win a second piece there's a deadly pin
and the black king could well just be
getting checkmated
no defense here for farugia he's trying
to get in with his black queen
what is the killer blow
wow he drops back his Knight and some
tricks here Magnus gives up a rook three
pieces for the queen this one's still
anyone's game
three pieces combining really well
though at the moment they are combining
very well in the piece the players are
just like slamming down the clock you
know you can feel the nerves I have to
say you know when it comes to Queen
versus three pieces it's all about
coordination and King safety and look at
how fast they're playing it's so easy to
play with a queen and for Russia has one
one Pawn back there we go all the pawns
are disappearing oh Magnus has put his
pieces on really clumsy squares just to
preserve his a pawn
yeah and the bishop is vulnerable
I don't think he's going to win it I
think Ferris played so well defended so
resourcefully and one of the white
Bishops doing they've just left their
King totally abandoned no the king wants
to go to the journey a round trip this
is risky do you think that there's any
chance that Magnus will actually loses
now that he's dropped his light oh my
God
this is what happens when you face a
queen in Blitz chess it's pretty much
bullet Chess at this point and all the
white pawns have dropped then White
Knight has dropped oh maybe he'll still
save the game because the pair of Bishop
a pawn a6a7 it's a race still enough for
all
we say that carefully
it can be morals but it can be
intercepted and now the king
swear to go step it back don't get in
the pawns way
the black queen can give some checks but
she cannot fight The Bishop's important
alone Black's H Pawn just too slow
covering everything
oh so nervous both players dropping the
pieces
visibly shaking here
and we see eventually a repetition moves
and it is after all that drama a draw
a roller coaster of a game and we still
have one more game running we certainly
do and well Fabiana Carona and Anish
Geary is still in play but big news
though did you see that Hikaru Nakamura
played the role of spoiler and beat
Shakura mamajov
so we will come to the standings later
Nakamura might well have got himself in
the top five at the last minute but this
game has gone down to a King and porn
end game between Carolina and Gary looks
like it should be a draw but you might
have to be very very careful if you're
carolana here the black king is itching
to get into the position king of
Portland games is so tricky and Gary's
coming around with the black king
could this be deadly could he just uh
shoulder off the white king and
infiltrate
oh look at that the evaluation bar does
drop black is suddenly winning the black
king has come in it's entering from
behind Judith yeah this is a good
technique the question is whether King
E2 King F5 can
oh yeah and now the King goes back and
grabs the phone now it's over
wow okay he's winning opponent scary but
is that the end of the game
he's been blocked off
yeah but the problem is the black king
cannot get around
okay F6 you have to give up your
opposition Yep looks looks like he's
coming in but not quite I love what
faby's doing he's blocking off the white
king really in kind of instructive stuff
here oh as soon as black pushes the F
Pawn everything will get traded down and
White's King will just hide in the
corner this might be one of those rare
exceptions being a pawn up is not
sufficient to win and uh Fabi takes the
opposition
in F2 yep yep just always drop back here
stare down the opposition King on the
same color there we go textbook
stuff I think E3 now works
King E1 might even work that's over the
played yep
just stay on the same color complex as
the opponent's can just copy their
Maneuvers essentially to keep the
opposition as we call it this is
the one G4 was winning
did he put his King on D1
wasn't it on the day file oh wow we
might have just seen some drama I think
we did uh see some huge slips there
Judith just for one second Anish giri
was winning but now it should be back to
being a draw I think it was under Diva
wasn't it
and eventually a handshake
the player's laughing maybe missed
opportunities for Anish Guru but great
defense from Fabiano
definitely great defense from the US
number two and there we see the players
analyzing they finished the tournament
they have finished but this was just a
precursor this was just a rehearsal it's
worth it oh oh the penny has dropped and
now they're talking probably about that
King to D1
yes there was a moment where the king
the white king came to D1 and black
could have won by just simply pushing
the G Pawn oh oh you don't you hate it
when your opponent points out those
things
and let's take a look at the round nine
scores it was a draw after a roller
coaster game between Magnus Carlsen and
alireza faroogia and in other news
Shakira mamajov lost to Hikaru Nakamura
so this was a very important point for
Hikaru perhaps he's moved into the top
five in the standings and for nordebec
Abdul satoroff it was a victory against
kukesh and a draw between Fabiana
Carolina and Anish giri as was a draw
between Ari antari and Wesley so
oh this is a fun afternoon
it was it was incredibly exhilarating I
mean I want more and we are gonna get
more yeah because tomorrow the main
event starts and and look who won the
event
wow from nowhere like their submarine it
is noribbeck Abdus who takes first place
in the blitz standings with an
incredible six points out of nine this
means that nordeback is given the first
choice to pick his seatings so if he
picks number one he will start the
tournament tomorrow with two whites
alireza gets second
gets a second place and second pickings
and so it continues and when it comes to
the fifth place because remember there
are five people who will start with
fight well not start who will play with
five whites and four blacks well that's
tied so that means it will have to go to
the tie break methods to decide who gets
those all-important first choices yeah
and we will await confirmation but it's
an All-American tie an All-American pile
up on uh Five Points out of nine Hikaru
Nakamura Fabiana karon and Wesley so one
of them is uh gonna miss out on that
all-important white but either way
congratulations to Abdu satorov he's a
man on form winning the chess kid Cup
last week and winning a blitz tournament
again now look at that with kind of not
even noticing it just one right there
was a focus on on Nakamura in the
beginning later on it was it was uh the
others firuza came up right and mamajaro
was always there in on the on the lead
then Magnus tried to give some hint that
he also wants to go up on the on the on
the top of the board of the satorov
right I mean it's been a shocking time
of events because I mean if we look at
the standings again Hikaru definitely
finished on sixth place so he will have
those five blacks and four well
assuming that the players all choose go
for those five whites and four blacks
and when it comes to Magnus Magnus
finishing in the bottom half of the
standings who would have thought that
actually I think he doesn't care so much
about the colors it matters about his
form and about that he's much more
worried if he is than about his colors
but of course I'm pretty sure that he
would favor white right yeah I think any
play at the top level would favor the
white pieces if possible but as you say
Magnus is going to worry about his form
but also there's one move blunders they
have plagued his game in Rapid chess and
Blitz chess in recent times and it
happened a lot again today
surprising stuff from the former world
champion but do you think that this
tournament will be a great way for say
someone like Magnus to shake off the
rust and get going
now that those blunders have been paid
yeah normally you want to get a few
games under your belt you see the board
a bit better you feel a bit sharper
especially if it comes down to
Armageddon but uh yeah either way
yeah magnus's confidence will be
slightly dented I have a feeling when I
wonder
I wonder how much uh his his up to play
classical game how much his appetite is
back for that you know because after
records that he said that he's kind of
bored right it's kind of boring he
prefers to play show the time controls
and now he's back and I'm sure he wants
to bite especially after today yeah I
don't think he's played a classical
tournament since January since uh Tata
steel his last classical game was
against uh me actually in March and yeah
he he didn't seem to be too kind of
thrilled with the classical chess but uh
yeah he'll he'll have to get motoring
tomorrow as all as well all the players
yeah indeed and let's remind ourselves
of those all important Blitz standings
because they will decide what players
get how many colors and also who will
start off with a double white and who
will start off with a double black and
if it all goes to CD we might see Hikaru
actually begin with a double black
well if he starts the tournament that
way then he'll be up against it from
game one but then again if he survives
the first two rounds then he'll be full
of confidence himself well we'll see
what happens but uh let's remind
ourselves of the standings
and What a Day surprises sharks roller
coaster games it's been brilliant it's
also interesting to see I think that how
emotionally emotionally players are
going through even just three hours on
this nine games right and here we can
remind ourselves of the standard and
they've been adjusted for the tie breaks
and we can see at the top of the table
Nordic Abdus toroff he will get the
first choice alireza faruga will
actually be the one getting second
pickings and Shakura mamajorov gets
their choice and this is very important
for Fabiana caruana and Wesley so they
finished on Five Points and they will
get fourth and fifth choice and Hikaru
them gets six choice so maybe he might
not go for number six
he might say I'll leave that that treat
for someone else and Magnus Carlson is
there in seventh place so it's been an
absolutely wonderful day of Chess so
much excitement so many surprises and I
think this is setting us up very nicely
for what is going to happen when the
main Tournament begins tomorrow and what
do you guys expect from that
well I'm expecting that the players will
just recover of today's all kind of
mistakes and problems and good moves and
nice moments and then tomorrow they come
sharp and they kick off with the with
some very interesting stuff and I think
this will be an extremely interesting
event coming up with all the ups and
downs because the generational clashes
also and and everybody's hungry I think
and they want to win
and there will be a winner because it is
Norway chess where we have Armageddon
yeah it really bodes well what we saw
today as you say Ivanka if the classical
games are drawn we head to Armageddon
and we saw the way the players were
fighting uh in these games we saw just
taking risks we saw them just kind of
going all out for the win and if that's
reflected in the Armageddon chess then
we're in for a treat so I can't wait to
get started tomorrow yes and uh someone
else who can't wait for the games to
begin tomorrow well that's us here in
the studio and I'd like to thank
everyone for watching and it's been a
day of Fighting Chess and let the games
continue tomorrow at 5 PM see you then
thank you
foreign